les rapporteurs sont là
merci
oui oui laisser place nette le ministre
monsieur le garde des sceaux
monsieur Savin merci vous pouvez vous
asseoir
allez ça y est là
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen des
crédits de la mission justice du projet
de loi de finance pour 2023 la parole
est immédiatement Monsieur Antoine
Lefebvre rapporteur spécial de la
commission des finances pour 7 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs pour avis de la commission
des lois mes chers collègues sur le
budget de la justice vous me permettrez
pour commencer par commencer par un
constat celui du comité des états
généraux de la justice le service public
de la justice est une institution qui
traverse une crise majeure c'est un
bateau naufragé qui n'a pas coulé à pic
mais qui a pris l'eau progressivement au
fil d'année de restriction budgétaire la
crise sanitaire a de ce point de vue
agit comme un révélateur de ces
dysfonctionnements c'est sous cet angle
que nous devons analyser le budget qui
nous est proposé pour l'année 2023 et
pour toutes les composantes de la
justice la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse l'administration pénitentiaire
la justice judiciaire le secrétariat
général du ministère et le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature un point
positif ce budget augmente pour
atteindre 11,6 milliards d'euros en
disant les crédits alloués à la justice
auraient augmenté de plus de moitié
pour ce qui concerne les effectifs 10000
postes devraient être créés d'ici 2027
dont 1500 magistrats et 1500 greffiers
les hausses successives sont absolument
essentielles pour remédier aux
défaillances de ce service public pour
citer les propos de Jean-Marc Sauvé
président du comité des Etats Généraux
on ne peut plus continuer d'appliquer
une multitude de rustines à une chambre
à air dont on n'a pas voulu voir qu'elle
était usé une réforme systémique
s'impose tant sur le fond que sur le
plan du budget monsieur le ministre la
future loi de programmation qui je
l'espère ne se rapprochement présenter
devra consacrer cette trajectoire il ne
s'agira pas bien sûr de vous donner un
blanc sain l'augmentation significative
des moyens du ministère de la Justice
depuis plusieurs années doit
s'accompagner de la diffusion d'une
réelle culture de l'évaluation des
dépenses réalisées telles que je la
conçois une loi de programmation ne doit
pas simplement constituer en la
définition d'indicateurs de performance
et de ligne de crédit et d'emploi elle
doit être l'occasion pour le ministère
concerné de s'interroger sur le sens des
politiques publiques qu'il mène sur la
qualité du service public qu'il soutient
et sur sa propre gestion des moyens
budgétaires comme humain la future loi
de programmation des moyens de la
justice ne pourra cet égard pas faire
l'économie d'une réflexion sur
l'amélioration de la gestion et sur la
construction
d'indicateurs de suivi fiable le
ministère c'est trop longtemps retrouvé
dans l'incapacité de relever les défis
d'une gestion rigoureuse pour reprendre
de nouveau un constat des États généraux
prenons un exemple le plan de
transformation numérique de la justice
le PTN il était initialement doté de 530
millions d'euros il est inconcevable que
la Cour des Comptes est due dans un
rapport remis à la demande de la
commission des finances admettre avoir
rencontré d'importantes difficultés pour
reconstituer les dépenses budgétaires
exécutées au titre du PTN l'informatique
fait d'ailleurs partie avec l'immobilier
et la gestion des ressources humaines
les trois chantiers qui doivent être
menés à bien pour se tenir le service
public de la justice je suis en effet
convaincu que l'institution judiciaire
ne sortira pas de sa crise majeure si
elle ne s'interroge pas de la gestion de
ces fonctions supports il faut les
rapprocher des utilisateurs avec un
impératif celui de mieux prendre en
compte les besoins des usagers de la
justice qu'il s'agisse des personnels
des justiciersiables ou des
professionnels du droit tels que les
avocats sur l'informatique un deuxième
plan de transformation numérique est
amené à prendre la suite du premier
établi pour la période 2018-2022 la
commission des Finances avait entendu la
Cour des comptes sur sa mise en oeuvre
au mois de février dernier soyons clairs
si le premier plan de transformation
numérique était un plan de rattrapage le
deuxième devrait être celui de la
modernisation pour réussir il devra non
seulement être doté de moyens
budgétaires suffisants mais également
tenir compte de plusieurs impératifs il
devra d'abord pleinement inclure les
usagers et leurs besoins alors que le
malaise grandit au sein des juridictions
sur les outils numériques il n'est pas
normal que la modification de certains
systèmes d'information oblige désormais
les magistrats et les greffiers à
ressaisir manuellement certaines données
ensuite le deuxième PTN devra conduire à
une véritable interopérabilité des
systèmes d'information du ministère par
exemple aucune application ne permet
aujourd'hui de fournir des données sur
le parcours complet des mineurs pris en
charge par la justice le décloisonnement
des applications devra donc s'opérer en
interne mais aussi en externe avec le
ministère de l'intérieur par exemple
mais aussi avec les professionnels du
droit comme les avocats le deuxième
enjeu est celui de la
professionnalisation de la gestion des
Ressources Humaines je suis convaincu
que le pilotage des ressources humaines
n'est pas seulement une question
d'augmentation des effectifs il implique
également de prendre en compte les
questions relatives
au vivier de recrutement ou à la
revalorisation de certains métiers en
perte d'attractivité il s'agit là d'un
enjeu capital qui ne peut pas se
contenter d'une seule réflexion sur la
rémunération j'en viens à la troisième
fonction support celle de l'immobilier
le plus grand chantier du ministère est
bien celui de la construction des 15000
places de détention supplémentaires sous
l'égide de l'administration
pénitentiaire je reste persuadé et nous
aurons l'occasion de vous entendre à ce
sujet monsieur le ministre lors de la
discussion de l'article 44 TER qu'une
politique pénitentiaire ne peut
toutefois pas se résumer à une politique
immobilière à l'inverse la politique
immobilière du ministère ne peut se
résumer au plan 15000 les programmes de
rénovation que ce soit des tribunaux
judiciaires ou des établissements de
détention sont absolument cruciaux ils
participent aussi de la valorisation des
magistrats des greffiers ou des
surveillants pénitentiaires au regard
des missions absolument essentielles
qu'ils accomplissent nous leur devons
d'améliorer leurs conditions d'exercice
voilà monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues les observations que je
souhaitais faire sur le projet de budget
du ministère de la Justice compte tenu
de l'effort budgétaire consenti sur la
mission j'ai proposé la commission des
finances de l'adopter laquelle a
souhaité suivre mon avis à l'unanimité
je vous remercie merci chers
pour la vie de la commission des lois
pour 3 minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues pour la
troisième année consécutive les crédits
à louer à l'administration pénitentiaire
dans le projet de loi de finance
s'inscrivent en forte hausse avec une
progression de 7,5%. ces moyens
supplémentaires ne sont pas superflus
compte tenu des besoins en moyenne
humain et des investissements
nécessaires pour rénover et développer
notre parc pénitentiaire pourtant les
auditions auxquelles j'ai procédé m'ont
parfois donné l'impression que les
efforts réalisés sur le plan budgétaire
n'avait pas encore d'effets perceptibles
sur le terrain je vois à cela deux
explications d'abord une part importante
des crédits est absorbée par le
programme 15000 qui vise à ouvrir 15000
de nouvelles places de prison d'ici à
2027 ensuite le retour de la
surpopulation carcérale dégrade les
conditions de travail du personnel ainsi
que les conditions de détention
concernant le programme 15000 je
rappelle qu'il est divisé en deux
tranches 7000 places devait être livré
entre 2017 et 2022 et 8000 entre 2022 et
2027 nous devons constater que la
première tranche a pris du retard
puisque le nombre de places livrées en
cette fin d'année 2022 et de l'ordre de
2000 la livraison d'une dizaine
d'établissements est prévu en 2023 ce
qui permettra de combler une partie de
ce retard
il n'en reste pas moins que l'achèvement
du programme à l'échéance prévue paraît
aujourd'hui bien incertain je
m'interroge en particulier sur les
surcos qui vont résulter de la hausse
des prix de l'énergie et des matières
premières qui pourraient inciter à
étaler dans le temps la mise en oeuvre
du programme après la baisse constatée
en 2020 du fait de la pandémie la
population carcérale est repartie à la
hausse pour se rapprocher désormais de
ses plus hauts niveaux historiques dans
les maisons d'arrêt le taux d'occupation
dépasse des 140% en moyenne avec des
pointes à plus de 200% dans certains
établissements par exemple à la prison
de Bordeaux Gradignan qui sur laquelle
la Contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté nous a alerté dans
ce contexte le gouvernement a fait
adopter à l'Assemblée nationale un
amendement qui reporte une nouvelle fois
la mise en application du principe de
l'insulinement individuel en évidence
des conditions observées sur le terrain
font obstacle au respect de ce principe
à compter du 1er janvier 2023 la
surpopulation général dégradent d'abord
les conditions de détention on observe
davantage de matelas au sol un accès
plus difficile aux activités sportives
ou culturelles et le suivi par les
conseillers pénitentiaires d'insertion
et de probation les spips tentent à se
passer ce qui réduit les chances de
réinsertion elle détériore aussi les
conditions de travail de personnel les
schéma d'emploi dans les établissements
sont définis en fonction du nombre de
places théorique mais non en fonction du
nombre de détenus réellement accueillis
d'où une importante surcharge de travail
notamment pour les surveillants
pénitentiaires quotidiennement au
contact des personnes incarcérées en
dépit de ces difficultés qui persistent
la commission des lois émis un avis
favorable à l'adoption des crédits de
l'administration pénitentiaire ainsi que
l’article rattaché 44 terres tout en
étant convaincu que la remise à niveau
mais notre cellule pénitentiaire
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des lois pour 3 minutes
gardez un peu le compteur ça fera du
bien tout le monde merci président
collègue en novembre 2021 3000
magistrats mettez la lumière dans une
tribune sur leur malaise profond un an
plus tard après les états généraux de la
justice ils sont toujours dans la rue or
le projet de budget pour 2023 poursuit
l'effort de rattrapage avec une hausse
des crédits de paiement de 8 % dans 300
millions supplémentaires pour les
juridictions alors pourquoi pourquoi
alors que le budget de la justice
augmente pour la troisième année
consécutive le malaise persiste pourquoi
malgré des recrutements en nombre les
délais de jugement s'allonge toujours
passant pour les affaires civiles de
11,4 mois en 2019 à 13,7 mois en 2021 et
après de 50 mois pour les crimes la
création en 2023 de 1220 postes dont 146
546 titulaires dont 200 magistrats 191
greffiers et 155 directeurs de greffe
doit permettre de renforcer des
juridictions cette dynamique devrait se
poursuivre avec la création sur cinq ans
de 1500 postes de magistrats 1500 postes
de greffiers et 2000 juristes assistants
ces moyens humains sont attendus
notamment à Nanterre ou un seul JAF très
îles à faire alors que la moyenne est de
108000 dans les autres juridictions
cette ambition impose de développer des
moyens de formation des personnels
recrutés et d'attirer de nouvelles
vocations pour cela le projet de loi de
finance prévoit une prime de 1000 € brut
en moyenne pour les magistrats
judiciaires moduler en fonction de
l'ancienneté pour les greffes un effort
de 165 euros brut par mois pour les
greffiers de 250 euros pour les
directeurs de greffe et prévus cette
augmentation et la reconnaissance du
rôle central des greffiers dans la
chaîne judiciaires mais ne permettra pas
l'amélioration réelle de leurs
conditions de travail tant qu'il y aura
7% de postes non pourvu et que les
conditions matérielles informatiques et
l'euro locaux ne seront pas améliorés je
pense particulièrement au greffes du
tribunal judiciaire de Rouen qui
travaille dans des conditions peu
acceptables pas de fenêtre bureau
partagé avec la salle de pause des
agents ou installer dans des anciens
toilettes et affectés faute de place
cette augmentation massive des effectifs
doit impérativement s'accompagner d'une
véritable politique de ressources
humaines l'évaluation de la charge des
magistrats que nous appelons nos vœux
depuis 5 ans devraient heureusement
aboutir fin 2022 mais il importe surtout
de moderniser les méthodes de travail du
magistrat en créant une équipe qui lui
permettra de se concentrer sur son
office de revaloriser le rôle des
greffiers et de donner un avenir au
contractuel cela nécessitera une
clarification des missions de chacun
aujourd'hui peu lisible entre les
assistantes justice et juristes
assistants les contractuels de justice
de proximité les assistances
spécialisées monsieur le ministre vous
êtes engagé sur le chemin long et
sinueux de la réforme de la justice si
nous considérons qu'il faut aller plus
vite il convient surtout d'éclaircir la
méthode les états généraux de la justice
donnent le guide il faut maintenant
fixer le cap ce budget est un bon début
c'est pourquoi la commission des lois a
émis un avis favorable merci chers
collègues
remarquable la parole est à nouveau pas
nouveau d'ailleurs enfin à Madame
Dominique verrière
rapporteur pour la commission des lois
pour 3 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
l'informatique évidemment
certes encore une fois les crédits
augmentent pourtant forcer de constater
que sur le terrain en dehors de l'aspect
matériel les évolutions concrètes sont
encore attendues nous signalons à chaque
fois nous en avons que nous en avons
l'occasion depuis plusieurs années
maintenant et nous continuerons à le
faire d'ailleurs si j'en crois le Canard
Enchaîné après le naufrage de la
numérisation des procédures civiles
pilotées par ce presteria et fgmini le
ministère a signé un nouveau marché de
45 millions avec
sopra Steria et Capgemini après tout ce
sont sans doute les mieux informés de ce
qu'il ne faut pas faire sur le
renforcement des effectifs Agnès
canailles vient de le dire je suis
évidemment en ligne avec elle et si je
loue cet effort notable le recrutement
doit s'accompagner de changement sur le
terrain et je pense que le rapport de
Dominique Lottin sur la structuration
des équipes juridictionnelles
pluridisciplinaires pourrait permettre
d'engager le changement sur des bases
concrètes enfin et vous savez que ce
sujet me tient à cœur la nouvelle
augmentation des crédits alloués à
l'accès aux droits et à l'aide aux
victimes
mais malheureusement lorsque la victime
a la chance d'être reconnue par même
lorsque la victime a la chance d'être
reconnue par l'institution elle se
heurte trop souvent à de grandes
difficultés dans le traitement de son
dossier voire de ces dossiers un chez le
juge aux affaires familiales un chez le
juge des enfants un au pénal avec des
décisions parfois contradictoires mais
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
ainsi que la première ministre
naturellement n'avoir fait confiance
pour conduire une mission sur les
violences intrafamiliales et nous
veillerons avec ma collègue Emilie
Chandler à vous faire des propositions
concrètes sur ce sujet et je peux d'ores
et déjà vous dire que les trois
premières d'entre elles seront formation
et formation et en effet on ne peut pas
traiter correctement ses dossiers si
l'on ne sait pas ce qu'est le
psychotraumatisme l'emprise le contrôle
coercitif est-ce que cela génère chez la
victime alors merci de cette mission et
même si tout n'est pas parfait merci de
ce budget
bien la parole est maintenant madame
Maryse Carrère également rapporteur pour
la ville de la commission des lois pour
3 minutes
[Musique]
en charge avant l'audience sanction le
sijpm peut être un levier de la
redynamisation du secteur ouvert qui est
un des axes de travail de la PJJ appuyez
sur les assises du placement judiciaire
Close en octobre dernier la tension
croissante portée au milieu ouvert
notamment par des créations de poste et
les moyens donnés aux unités éducatives
d'accueil de jour et bienvenue au cours
des dernières années nous avons en effet
eu l'occasion de nous inquiéter de la
place très importante prise par la
création des cèfles dans l'augmentation
du budget de la PJJ près d'un quart sur
les trois dernières années alors même
que les besoins du milieu ouvert sont
très importants j'en viens donc à la
question des centres éducatifs fermés
dans le développement a constitué un axe
majeur de la politique du gouvernement
ces dernières années sur le programme de
20 nouveaux CF il semble aujourd'hui que
la PJJ soit amenée à renoncer à trois ou
quatre projets qui ne pourront aboutir
parallèlement de nouveaux projets de
self sont envisagés sous-jacent aux
difficultés de la PJJ et la question des
personnels il s'agit là d'une véritable
inquiétude en raison d'un taux de
vacances de poste de 6% et un niveau de
rotation élevé sur plusieurs postes
difficiles le taux de contractuel dans
la PJJ supérieur à 20% et leur
renouvellement est lui aussi élevé si de
nouveaux postes sont créés chaque année
nous avons noté par le passé que tous ne
parviennent pas à être pourvu face à ce
manque d'attractivité la revalorisation
salariale est nécessaire mais elle n'est
apparemment pas suffisante au moins à
court terme il faut également redonner
du sens au métier de la PJJ avec des
orientations mobilisatrices et la
volonté d'agir pour l'insertion des
jeunes
les moyens déployés à cette fin peuvent
aller dans ce sens un dernier point sur
le déploiement de l'applicatif parcours
l'appropriation de l'outil s'est avérée
particulièrement difficile et le besoin
de formation important la PJJ a donc
relancé un programme de formation des
personnels de nouveaux développements
saveurs nécessaires mobilisant 4
millions d'euros en 2022 et à nouveau en
2023 pour permettre le déploiement du
deuxième lot de parcours destiné aux
éducateurs eux-mêmes pour leur au regard
de l'augmentation du budget la
commission des lois a donné un avis
favorable à l'adoption des crédits du
programme 182 je vous remercie merci
chers collègues dans la suite de notre
discussion je vous rappelle que le temps
de parole la tribu à chaque groupe pour
chaque unité de discussion comprend le
temps d'intervention générale et celui
de l'explication de votre par ailleurs
le gouvernement disposera au total de 15
minutes à l'issue de la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur Thomas
do su pour le groupe écologiste pour 5
minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur est
rapporte pour avis chers collègues le
budget de la justice pour 2023 est
présenté dans la foulée des états
généraux de la justice qui sont qui ont
rendu leur conclusion le 8 juillet 2022
certes ces étages généraux ont permis de
renouer un dialogue perdu entre les
acteurs de la justice et les pouvoirs
publics le budget sur les trois
dernières années bénéficie d'une
augmentation significative de ce crédit
nous devrions nous féliciter de cette
prise de conscience mais derrière les
effets d'annonce la réalité était lasse
plus compliquée les difficultés
structurelles des juridictions sont
considérables et notre système
judiciaire est à bout de souffle la
justice française est l'une des plus
mauvaises élèves de l'Union européenne
elle compte 3 procureurs pour 100000
habitants contre 12 en moyenne dans les
États membres un budget qui demeure
inférieur à celui des autres pays
européens incomparables avec un budget
de 5 euros par habitant consacrés à
l'aide du résurrectionnelle la France se
situe encore en dessous de la moyenne
européenne qui est à 6,5 euros par
habitant
une moyenne un exemple très parlant
illustre les défaillances et
l'encombrement de notre justice une
dépêche interministérielle datée de mai
2021 à inciter les magistrats à classer
sans suite de très nombreuses affaires
jugées trop anciennes ou pour lesquelles
aucune enquête n'a été menée ces
injonctions illustrent tous les chèques
de notre système judiciaire la justice
française souffre également d'une
sous-évaluation chronique des besoins
humains dans les juridictions à titre
d'exemple le taux de vacances des postes
de greffiers s'établit à 7,2% soit 2,7
points de plus qu'en 2019 avant la crise
covid-19
les embauches de près de 200 magistrats
et 198 greffiers ne pourront hélas
répondre aux besoins que représentent
les postes non pourvu sur ces postes
nous dénonçons également la méthode du
gouvernement qui consiste en une
embauche massive de contractuel
ces assistants de justice contractuels
en situation précaire remplace à bas
coût les recrutements de magistrats
cette politique de recrutement à moindre
coût n'est pas une solution pérenne
acceptable pour notre pays elle illustre
la logique gestionnaire à courte vue qui
s'impose de plus en plus au détriment de
la qualité de la justice rendue et de
l'accès à la justice pour tous les
citoyens
des moyens supplémentaires seront en
outre alloués au bracelet anti
rapprochement ces outils dès leur
création ont connu de nombreux
dysfonctionnements techniques ce qui a
conduit le ministère à changer de
prestataire en 2022 cet exemple montre
qu'en dépit des moyens supplémentaires
le pilotage fait parfois défaut enfin
que dire du budget colossal Allué à la
construction de nouvelles prisons en
dépit de nombreuses condamnations de la
France par la CEDH pour les conditions
indignes de détention aucune réflexion
n'est abordée quant à l'architecture des
parcs actuels et sur l'entre l'entretien
des établissements existants alors que
cela permettrait d'améliorer rapidement
la qualité de vie des tenues et les
conditions de travail des surveillants
pénitentiaires la promise de la promesse
de 15000 places pour 2027 défendues
comme un remède aux problèmes chroniques
de supropulation nous paraît
inappropriés le taux d'occupation des
places en maison d'arrêt pourrait ainsi
atteindre plus de 130% en 2023 les
subventions aux associations destinées à
financer les activités culturelles et
sportives des détenus connaissent une
diminution importante de 25%. alors que
les activités organisées au sein de la
détention participe au quotidien
carcéral et s'inscrivent pleinement dans
un parcours de réinsertion dans ces
conditions comment espérer une véritable
amélioration des conditions de détention
vous annoncez également des créations de
poste de surveillance mais nous savons
tous ici que celui de sera difficile à
mobiliser puisque cette proposition
souffre d'une en vérité d'une grave
crise de vocation en raison notamment
des conditions de travail et de
rémunération qui ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux et des missions
effectuées par ces agents j'aurais un
dernier mot sur la protection judiciaire
de la jeunesse qui au gré des réformes
et des budgets restent le parent pauvre
de la justice certes la PJJ bénéficie
d'une hausse budgétaire mais la priorité
donnée par le gouvernement est fléchi
sur la création de place dans des
centres éducatifs fermés ou renforcés la
culture du Tour répressif assez limite
surtout pour ce qui est de notre
jeunesse tout délinquante qu'elle soit
c'est pourquoi même si dans la globalité
nous saluons l'augmentation du budget de
la mission la justice la répartition des
crédits ne répond pas suffisamment aux
besoins de recrutement de personnels ne
pallient pas les problématiques de la
justice de quotidien ni celles du besoin
d'améliorer rapidement les conditions de
détention dans notre pays notre groupe
s'abstiendra donc sur les budgets de
cette mission je vous remercie merci
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
à Monsieur tanima pour le groupe RDPI
pour 6 minutes
c'est le Président c'est le garde des
sceaux Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs ce président de la
commission des lois mes chers collègues
fidèle à vos engagements vous avez
obtenu monsieur le garde des sceaux pour
la troisième année consécutive un budget
important pour 2023 puisque les crédits
alloués au ministère de la Justice
augmente de nouveau de 8%. cette hausse
est d'autant plus opportune que les
états généraux de la Justice ont mis un
exergue l'impériose nécessité de
maintenir une trajectoire ambitieuse
cela a été rappelé à de nombreuses
reprises le budget de la justice a
augmenté de 26% depuis votre entrée au
gouvernement et de 40% depuis le début
du premier quinquennat du président
Macron ce qui est considérable certes
notre enthousiasme doit être tempérée
car ce changement de braquer opérer
depuis trois ans n'inverse pas encore la
tendance et la France demeure l'un des
pays d'Europe qui consacre moins
d'argent à sa justice la mobilisation
organisée mardi un an après une tribune
qui avait dénoncé la souffrance au
travail de la profession judiciaire et
une des illustrations de ce qu'il reste
encore beaucoup pas faire pour améliorer
la justice dans notre pays et souligne
une impatience bien légitime des
professionnels du droit cependant nous
ne serions pas honnêtes si nous ne
reconnaissions pas les grandes avancées
que permettra ce beau budget d'abord un
terme de moyens humains puisque ces
crédit rendront possible un renforcement
des effectifs de 1253 en plats un emploi
seront créés cette année l'amélioration
des conditions de travail des agents et
de la qualité du service rendu 80
millions d'euros sont prévus pour
revaloriser les salaires de tous les
agents du ministère
des magistrats qui feront les
rémunérations augmenter de 1000 euros
brut par mois en moyenne aux éducateurs
en passant par les surveillants
pénitentiaires le budget permettra
également de poursuivre les programmes
immobiliers judiciaire et pénitentielles
s'agissant de l'administration
pénitentiaire et alors que nous
connaissons un retour à une sorte
population carcérale endémique le
gouvernement a décidé de poursuivre la
sécurisation et la modernisation du
service public pénitentiaire la création
de nouvelles places de prison dans le
cadre du Plan 15000 doit nécessairement
s'accompagner du développement des
aménagements de peine et des mesures
alternatives à l'incarcération à ce
titre je salue les efforts déployés par
le gouvernement pour favoriser la
réinsertion des personnes placées sous
main de justice et me réjouit de la
hausse des crédits consacrés à la mise
en place du statut du détenu travailleur
qui aidera à prévenir la récidive à
maintenir un climat apaisé en la hausse
des moyens consacrés au renforcement de
la sécurité des personnels et des
établissements est à souligner également
la montée en puissance du rôle du
surveillant en pénitentiaire l'ouverture
de nouvelles unités pour détenus
violents la généralisation des caméras
piétons sont autant de mesure qui
permettront de lutter plus efficacement
contre les violences au sein de nos
établissements pénitentiaires enfin des
efforts renouvelés les conséquents sont
déployés en faveur de la modernisation
de la justice et du renforcement de
l'accès au droit aussi je souhaite
souligner l'augmentation des crédits
destinés aux investissements numériques
de se consacrer au frais de justice pour
renforcer notamment les moyens
d'enquêter d'expertise judiciaires des
crédits dédiés à l'accès aux droits et à
la médiation de ceux à louer à l'aide
juridictionnelle ou encore de ceux
affecter à l'aide aux victimes qui
contribuera à une meilleure justice de
proximité c'est le garde des sceaux je
manquerai à tous mes devoirs
si je ne vous réinterrogez pas sur les
annonces que vous avez faites lors de
votre déplacement à Mayotte en mars
dernier et particulièrement c'est le
relative à la création d'une nouvelle
cité judiciaire d'un deuxième centre
pénitentiaire ou encore des centres
éducatifs fermés comprenez mon
assistance mais j'espère que vous aurez
de nouvelles précisions sur le
calendrier de mise en oeuvre la
réalisation de ces projets prendra
nécessairement du temps de temps que
nous faisons face à un énorme problème
de foncier qui pourrait retarder la
concrétisation de ces indispensables
évolution néanmoins que peut-il être
entrepris immédiatement pour traiter et
juguler la terrifiante flambée de la
délinquance juvénile que l'on peut
observer sur place le groupe RDPI que je
représente considère que ce budget
d'autres le ministère de la Justice de
moyens à la hauteur de ses missions il
accéléra il accélèrera sa modernisation
mettra en oeuvre les recommandations
issues des états généraux de la justice
ainsi que les mesures contenues dans la
loi confiance dans l'institution
judiciaire voilà pourquoi nous voterons
sans trembler ses crédit
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant aux questions jean-Pierre
Sueur pour le groupe socialiste pour 5
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux messieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le Président de la Commission
mes chers collègues
les états généraux de la justice sont
dressés un constat très alarmant
évoquant je cite une institution en état
de délabrement avancé aussi Monsieur le
Ministre
allons-nous saluer pour commencer
l'augmentation de
7,8%
des crédits de la justice soit 710
millions d'euros de plus qu'en 2022
après une hausse de 8% durant deux
années consécutives
bien entendu nous ne pouvons méconnaître
et vous non plus monsieur le ministre le
poids de l'inflation parce que lorsque
l'inflation est de 6 l'augmentation de 8
et bien conduit au calcul que vient de
publier oralement madame de La Gontrie
c'est-à-dire que l'augmentation se
trouve singulièrement
réduite mais un effort et inconstesse
incontestablement fait
rappelons tout de même que la France et
c'est le fruit d'une longue carence très
longue la France reste bien au-dessous
de la moyenne européenne avec 72,5 euros
par habitant consacré à la justice
contre 78 euros en moyenne
et que l'on doit encore continuer pour
atteindre les objectifs qui ont été
préconisées par les États généraux
s'agissant de la protection judiciaire
de la jeunesse les crédits augmentent de
10,4%, vous prévoyez monsieur le
ministre la construction de nouveaux
centres éducatifs mais je dois toutefois
rappeler les conclusions de la mission
sénatoriale dont faisait partie notre
collègue Laurence harrippé d'autres
collègues aussi de la commission des
lois qui ont assisté beaucoup sur le
manque de suivi scolaire au sein de ses
centres et nous pensons que Monsieur
Munich que vous serez à coeur de prendre
en compte les conclusions de ce travail
qui a été accompli par le Sénat
en ce qui concerne l'administration
pénitentiaire
vous nous dites bien sûr qu'il y aura
15000 nouvelles places de prison dans un
temps que nous ne connaissons pas
exactement ça fait d'ailleurs longtemps
qu'on en parle votre prédécesseur en
parler déjà et ça prédécesseur également
toutefois vous savez que depuis
1990 on a créé 36 000 places de prison
pour lutter contre la surpopulation mais
la surpopulation restait constante
donc est-ce que le fait de créer de
nouvelles places de prison
permet de réduire la surpopulation c'est
une question
et
nous reconnaissons ce qui a été annoncé
nous pensons que tout aussi important en
même plus important que la création de
nouvelles places est sans doute la
restauration de place et
d’établissements qui sont dans un état
de délabrement de décrépitude et ce qui
a donné lieu vous le savez à la
condamnation de la France par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour
des conditions d'indignité je cite dans
de détention dans un certain nombre
d'établissements alors je vais vous
redire les chiffres vous les connaissez
par cœur Monsieur le Ministre
il y avait au 1er septembre dernier
71669 détenus pour
60715 places soit 120% de surpopulation
plus de 130% dans les maisons-rées et
dans 36 établissements plus de
150%. ça veut dire qu'il y a 2000 êtres
humains qui aujourd'hui sont dans des
cellules de 9 mètres carrés à 3
et qui dorment sur des matelas sur le
sol au mépris de toutes les conditions
d'intimité que l'on est au l'endroit de
d'attendre dans nos prisons
et je rappelle
ce qu'avait dit il y a une vingtaine
d'années Robert Badinter il avait dit la
condition pénitentiaire et la première
cause de la récidive donc nous pensons
qu'il faut vraiment écouter ce qu'on dit
les
états généraux de la justice et je sais
que vous y serez sensible monsieur le
garde des sceaux les états généraux de
la justice préconisent un mécanisme de
régulation ce sera votre conclusion ce
testeur merci connu non non monsieur
le construire le temps est contraint
pour vous comme pour moi merci j'espère
que
merci Monsieur le testeur la parole est
à Madame ku Kerman
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux mes chers collègues le
service public que représente la justice
nécessite soutient et considération il
est vrai que vous nous présentez une
augmentation du budget de la justice de
près de 8% et le ministère de la Justice
se félicite même d'un triplé historique
pour autant à notre sens mais également
au sens je crois de nombreux acteurs du
monde judiciaire ces efforts budgétaires
demeurent insuffisants pour combler les
difficultés structurelles de la justice
nous partons de trop loin l'institution
judiciaire est dans un état plus que
dégradé et les crises internes qu'elle
nous présente nous demande d'agir en
toute responsabilité
nous dénonçons donc un budget de la
justice qui se situe toujours parmi les
moins élevés en Europe
à l'heure où la souffrance des acteurs
judiciaires n'est pas minimisé nous
soutenons ceux qui dénoncent le
rendement au prix d'une justice humaine
aujourd'hui le temps de l'écoute et de
l'étude n'est malheureusement pas celui
de la justice française ce n'est pas du
fait de nos magistrats mais bien de 20
ans d'abandon humain et budgétaire de la
justice par les différents ministères
successifs malgré les efforts les
efforts pardon de cette année nous
demeurons face à nos yeux à une justice
qui continuera de se faire au rabais à
titre d'exemple s'agissant du nombre de
juges professionnels la France compte on
juge pour 100.000 habitants contre 22 en
moyenne en Europe cet écart d'effectif
entre la France les autres pays
européens se manifestent également ceux
qui concerne l'effectif des personnels
non jugent indispensables au
fonctionnement de la justice tels que
les greffiers les assistants spécialisés
qui sont également moins nombreux en
France que dans d'autres pays
nous le martelons certes depuis des
années et nous refaisons cette année il
faut donner des moyens aux juridictions
et suspendre les réformes leur mise en
oeuvre sur un rythme accéléré sans
augmentation parallèle des crédits ni
fournitures des outils informatiques
adaptés engendre l'épuisement du système
judiciaire
par ailleurs nous constatons que
l'administration pénitentiaire se voit
accorder une hausse de budget pour 2023
de 268 millions d'euros néanmoins les
moyens restent nettement insuffisants au
vu de la menace grandissante qui pèse
sur le personnel pénitentiaire les
difficultés de cette administration sont
omniprésentes pour n'en citer que
certaines les heures supplémentaires
demeurent trop nombreuses trop
nombreuses le rythme de travail de nos
personnels pénitentiaires et tarascants
et face à cela vous concentrez les
moyens sur l'extension du parc castéral
une mesure qui ne permettra pas de sur
quoi de résoudre le problème de la
surpopulation carcérale à ce propos
rappelons que les taux d'incarcération
et de surpopulation carcérale en France
sont là à l'inverse parmi les plus
élevés d'Europe les conditions de
détention indignes dans les prisons
françaises sont régulièrement dénoncés
depuis de nombreuses années et la loi du
8 avril 2021 et certains intervenus de
garantir le droit au respect de la
dignité en prison mais ne constitue pas
une réponse totale au problème posé par
les mauvaises conditions de détention et
la surpopulation carcérale enfin il
convient d'insister sur la nécessité
d'octroyer à la justice des mineurs des
moyens humains et matériels conséquents
afin que la détection des violences et
la protection des enfants ne soient pas
illusoire parce que là encore nous
demeurons convaincus que la prévention
et la première efficacité en matière de
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
vous comprendrez et vous l'aurez deviné
nous ne voterons pas ce budget justice
tel qu'il est présenté car il ne répond
pas suffisamment à nos yeux aux enjeux
humains auxquels nous devons faire face
aux enjeux auxquels doivent faire face
nos concitoyens justiciables aux enjeux
auxquels doivent faire face les
différents personnels de justice je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est maintenant Monsieur Arnaud de belney
pour le groupe Union centriste pour 8
minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues le
budget que vous nous présentez
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre et sans
aucun doute ambitieux et s'inscrit dans
une dynamique plus réelle les crédits
alloués par exemple à la justice
judiciaire sont en hausse pour la
troisième année consécutive cela
démontre par les chiffres que je me
rappellerai pas car ils ont déjà été
largement détaillées par mes collègues
l'engagement du gouvernement en faveur
du monde judiciaire qui en attend besoin
mais les états généraux de la Justice
ont confirmés une fois encore un
diagnostic maintes fois répété notre
justice va mal elle est lente elle est
lente parce qu'elle est débordée ces
personnels sont souvent souffrances
démotivées parmi les annonces récentes
l'augmentation substantielle dont vont
bénéficier les magistrats en 2023 et
naturellement une très bonne chose elle
leur permettra d'être rétribué à
l'instar de leurs homologues des
juridictions administratives et sans
doute Dav à la hauteur de leur
investissement professionnel et des
lourdes responsabilités qui sont les
leurs car aujourd'hui de la motivation
il en faut pour les personnels de votre
ministère c'est vrai des surveillants
pénitentiaires qui souffrent d'un
déficit d'image c'est vrai pour les
greffiers et les magistrats traitant de
la justice pénale j'entendais encore
cette semaine à l'occasion d'un
rassemblement devant le TJ de Paris le
témoignage d'un magistrat décrivant une
audience de comparution immédiate qui
s'est terminée à 5 heures du matin mais
c'est vrai aussi et on en parle beaucoup
moins pour la justice civile cette
justice du quotidien rarement sur le
devant de la scène médiatique ni sur le
devant de la scène politique d'ailleurs
mais qui est pourtant bien souvent la
seule justice à laquelle seront
confrontés nos concitoyens au cours de
leur vie elle est le plus souvent passée
sous le boisseau là aussi la situation
est alarmante les magistrats en
souffrent bien sûr avec une charge de
travail considérable qui conduit
certains d'entre eux à questionner une
perte de sens de leur travail mais nous
coûte citoyens aussi notamment en raison
de la lenteur du processus judiciaire
qui a d'ailleurs déjà entraîné des
condamnations de la France nous savons
tous ici qu'en vertu de l'article 6 1 de
la Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme toute personne a droit à ce que
sa cause soit entendue dans un délai
raisonnable par un tribunal lors d'un
récent déplacement au Québec vous avez
réaffirmé monsieur le garde des sceaux
votre volonté de développer largement le
règlement des litiges à l'amiable on ne
peut que s'en féliciter car l'expérience
montre que c'est de nature à améliorer
la compréhension par nos concitoyens des
décisions rendues mais aussi à accélérer
la conclusion de nombreux litiges une
justice plus rapide et mieux comprise en
somme
mais pour pouvoir développer la
médiation et la conciliation il faut
d'abord que magistrat et avocat où il
faut aussi que magistrat et avocat se
forment qu'il soit plus sensibilisé sur
le sujet et c'est sans doute là aussi
qu'il faudra améliorer les choses nous
aurons l'occasion
d'aborder à nouveau ces sujets dans le
cadre de la loi de programmation qui est
encore en préparation et qui prendra la
suite de celle portée par votre
prédécesseur pour la période 2018 22
cette loi de programmation nous
permettra au-delà de la discussion
budgétaire pour 2023 d'aborder la
question des investissements à long
terme de votre ministère notamment en
matière immobilière
comme vous l'avez rappelé lors de votre
audition devant notre commission il faut
prévoir et préparer l'accueil des
recrutements que vous avez annoncé cela
passe par des investissements massifs
dans l'immobilier de nos juridictions
elles en ont cruellement besoin il
s'agit de mieux accueillir les
justiciables bien sûr mais aussi
d'améliorer les conditions de travail
des agents actuels et des renforces
humains qui viendront au cours des cinq
années à venir en la matière la marge de
progression est importante
on regrette aujourd'hui au delà de
l'état général de certains bâtiments le
manque d'autonomie dans la gestion du
quotidien des tribunaux
remplacer une ampoule
effectuer des travaux d'entretien ou de
réparation basique autant d'éléments sur
lesquels chaque chef de juridiction
devrait être capable d'agir rapidement
et de manière autonome avec des moyens
dédiés suffisants sans devoir rentrer
dans un processus administratif lourd et
inutile pas développer ici sur la
question de l'introduction des chiens
pour les victimes au pénal et de la
question de qui s'occupe du chien
c'est valable
oui les chiens pour les jeunes victimes
ou pénales pour qu'elles soient plus
sereine et adouci par la présence d'un
animal
c'est valable aussi pour les fournitures
la fameuse pénurie de ramette de papier
c'est encore le quotidien de nos
juridictions sans parler des logiciels
dont à qui ont déjà été évoqués par
notre collègue Dominique verrière
un mot sur l'un des articles rattachés à
cette mission l'article 44 TER
qui prolonge jusqu'au 31 décembre 2027
la possibilité de déroger au principe
dans ces éléments individuels des
personnes détenues en maison d'arrêt
avec un taux dans cellulement individuel
de seulement
20,1%. il était bien sûr illusoire de
penser que nous serions capables de
respecter ce principe au 31/2 au 31
décembre 2022 pardon
mais nous ne cessons de prolonger ce
moratoire depuis la loi pénitentiaire de
et voudrais bien accepter que je
rappelle ici que ce droit d'enseignement
individuel date d'une loi de 1875
en conséquence continue à brandir cet
objectif a-t-il encore un sens je ne le
crois pas sur le plan des principes ou
des objectifs à atteindre en revanche
probablement mais d'un point de vue
juridique je crains que ce type de
moratoire en est de moins en moins
espérons que le vote de cette énième
prolongement de moratoire permettra
notamment avec votre programme de
création de 15000 places de prison de
faire bouger les choses un peu plus vite
monsieur le ministre nous saluons les
arbitrages budgétaires que vous avez
réussi à obtenir dans le cadre de la
mission justice du PLF pour 2023 le
groupe de l'Union centriste apportera
son soutien à l'adoption de ses crédits
et nous attendons avec impatience avec
vigilance votre loi de programmation en
espérant qu'ils permettra d'inscrire
dans la durée le rattrapage du retard
accumulé ces dernières décennies nous
gardons à l'esprit que la France
consacre aujourd'hui 72 euros et 50
centimes par habitant à son système
judiciaire
près de deux fois moins que l'Allemagne
la France est le seul des grands pays
européens a consacré moins de 0,3% de
son PIB à la justice
ailleurs mais ici aussi la paix sociale
vaut davantage je vous remercie chers
collègues de votre attention merci cher
collègue
gue remarquable c'est bien merci
elle est la parole est Madame master
Benbassa non inscrite pour 3 minutes
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteur mes chers
collègues
je voudrais d'abord évoquer la mémoire
de Charlotte
l'histoire tragique d'une jeune
magistral de 29 ans qui s'est donné la
mort le 23 août 2021 à Béthune envoyer
des tribunaux en tribunaux elle comblait
les effectifs manquants des juridictions
du Nord à ces conditions de travail
difficiles s'ajouter des injonctions
d'aller toujours plus vite syndrome
d'une justice malade qui préfère un
jugement rapide et dégradé un jugement
de qualité à la suite de son suicide une
pétition réunissant 3000 magistrats et
plus de sang greffiers voient le jour et
condamne une justice qui n'écoute pas et
qui chronomètre tout
parlons de la magistrate Marie Truchet
qui s'est écroulée en plein audience de
comparution immédiate le 18 octobre
dernier au tribunal de Nanterre et qui
ne sait plus jamais relevé ce ne sont
pas des faits anecdotes ce sont des vies
humaines sacrifiées en raison d'une
justice à bout de souffle les états
généraux de la Justice ont confirmé
d'ailleurs le délabrement avancé de
notre système judiciaire qui ne parvient
plus à exercer ses missions dans des
conditions satisfaisantes cette semaine
la grève des magistrats et greffier à ce
sujet est une illustration
supplémentaire du ras-le-bol qui règne
au sein du corps judiciaire dans son
rapport le comité des États généraux
mais l'accent également sur l'importance
de la réinsertion en prison ainsi une
augmentation significative de crédit est
alloué à l'insertion professionnelle des
détenus dans 2 8 millions d'euros pour
le renforcement du statut de détenu
travailleur et 2 millions d'euros
consacrés à la diversification des
actions de réinsertion je résumé qu'on
s'endigne autant sur l'état de nos
prisons commencer un petit indigné pour
le karting à la maison d'arrêt de
Fresnes mais nombreuses visites en
prison me permettent d'attester que les
prisons françaises ne répondent pas à
l'exigence de dignité dont tout être
humain a le droit nous ne soignerons pas
le fléau de la surpopulation car cela
carcéral par l'élargissement du parc
immobilier carcéral la solution est
ailleurs héréside comme vous le savez
dans l'aménagement des courbes peines
monsieur le ministre on ne peut nier
tous les efforts financiers entreprises
dernières années ces trois dernières
années pour redresser le budget de la
justice néanmoins 9,6 millions d'euros
suffiront-ils pour faire oublier ce qui
a été trop longtemps négliger vu les
efforts faits je voterai pour ce budget
notre justice en tout cas nécessite une
réforme structurelle de fond à tous les
niveaux merci merci chers collègues la
parole est maintenant au président
Stéphane Artano pour 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux mesdames Messieurs le
rapporteur mes chers collègues voilà
maintenant trois ans que la justice de
notre pays rattrape progressivement
notre retard budgétaire nous partons
nous partons de loin les bidons des
derniers rapports d'évaluation de la
Commission européenne pour l'efficacité
de la justice montrer que la France
avait une dépense moyenne par habitant
et ça a été rappelé pour la justice
judiciaire en dessous de la moyenne
européenne les récents exercices
budgétaires devraient renverser cette
tendance il y a bien sûr lieu de son
réjouir et de poursuivre nos efforts
aussi pour l'ensemble nous saluons les
principales mesures de ce budget qu'il
s'agisse du financement des
revalorisations indemnitaires des
magistrats et greffiers et recrutements
nécessaires de la nouvelle hausse des
crédits budgétaires portés par
l'augmentation des frais de justice et
par l'immobilier judiciaire ou encore du
développement des aménagements des
peines et les mesures alternatives à
l'incarcération tout cela nous semble
aller dans le la bonne direction pour
2023 les crédits demandés sur la mission
justice connaissent une augmentation
inscrite dans la continuité des deux
exercices budgétaires précédents la
dynamique observée en matière d'emploi
doit être soulignée car je vais insister
là dessus les mots de la justice dans
notre société se résume souvent à des
questions de temps d'un côté le temps
d'attente d'un jugement est trop long
pour le justiciable dont l'impatience se
justifie de l'autre le temps disponible
des juridictions et trop limité ce qui
entrave leur incapacité à rendre des
décisions suffisamment motivées et
comprise par nos concitoyens aussi
toutes ces annonces budgétaires vont
dans le bon sens mais du chemin restent
encore à parcourir pour que notre
justice retrouve une place légitime dans
l'esprit de nos concitoyens qu'il
retrouve cette fameuse confiance dans
l'institution judiciaire tout le monde
pense spontanément à la justice pénale
ça a été rappelé mais d'autres services
sont également s'illustrer je pense en
particulier à la protection judiciaire
de la jeunesse ou de nombreux
établissements sont saturés en raison
d'un manque de personnel et font face à
des difficultés de recrutement comme à
souligné dans son rapport notre collègue
Maryse Carrère
qu'il s'agisse des éducateurs des chefs
de services ou des psychologues soit il
n'y en a pas assez soit les postes sont
souvent vacants en raison d'une faible
attractivité et d'une rotation élevée
dans les services
dans ce cas comme ailleurs la hausse des
crédits et salutaire mais elle ne suffit
pas à désengorger il faut ajouter à ce
constat que régulièrement la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme ne
manque pas d'entrée en condamnation
vis-à-vis de la France en raison de la
durée excessive de ces procédures
évidemment personne dans cette hémicycle
non visagerait de céder à ses désirs
d'archaïsme ceux d'une justice
expéditive et hasardeuse il demeure
néanmoins que de manière assez régulière
il est proposé des réformes d'ordre
procédural suivant des perspectives de
simplification et d'allègement je pense
par exemple à la collégialité dans
l'usage et de plus en plus rare
d'ailleurs dans les juridictions ou même
plus radicalement l'exclusion du recours
au juge
en ce sens par exemple le Sénat avait
montré sa prudence et notre groupe avait
dit ces inquiétudes lors de l'examen de
la loopnie au sujet de la généralisation
de l'amende forfaitaire délictuelle si
notre justice est trop lente chacun
s'accorde à dire et puisqu'il faut donc
trouver des solutions nous croyons aussi
qu'elle ne doivent pas consister à
renoncer à notre procédure pénale
ça complexité participe à ce que les
décisions qui ont les mêmes soient
équilibrées afin qu'elles répondent aux
vertus de prudence de tempérance et de
justice et de force auquel notre
République aspire
aussi plutôt que des procédures
simplifiées nous préférons observer un
renforcement des moyens humains comme
matériel ou également des formations les
magistrats greffiers et avocats
expriment régulièrement leur mal-être
que ce soit par des grèves ou via des
tribunes de presse ils nous font part de
leur surcharge de travail de leur
découragement et de leur épuisement
mais je suis également certain qu'aucun
d'entre eux ne voudrait renoncer au
principe fondamentaux de notre justice
il faut donc continuer de former de
recruter sans jamais dévoyer notre droit
processuel pour se faire il faut des
moyens ce budget en donne nous le salons
mais l'effort n'est pas encore achevé la
future loi de programmation qui est
annoncée devra s'inscrire dans sa
dynamique vous l'aurez compris tout en
restant vigilant le groupe RDSE votre en
faveur des crédits accordés à cette
mission merci chers collègues la parole
est maintenant au président François
Noël buffet pour le groupe les
républicains pour 12 minutes
je vais essayer de faire moi aussi tu
fais moins je te baigner
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre regarde des choses monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs
c'est probablement une intervention qui
parlera peu de chiffres
laissons rapporteur la qualité de leur
propre rapport et l'évocation de ces
sujets financiers pour tenir à propos au
titre du groupe un peu plus général
tout d'abord je voudrais
évoquer l'idée que
la situation de notre justice
a été évoquée au Sénat depuis longtemps
et singulièrement par un rapport qui
avait fait date celui de 2017
de la commission des Lois du Sénat
au terme rapport au terme duquel un
constat avait été évidemment établi et
surtout un principe qui était celui de 5
ans pour sauver notre justice il
préconisait à l'époque la remise à
niveau des moyens humains et matériels
des services judiciaires et
pénitentiaires
se traduisant par une note programmation
pour la justice élaborée dans une grande
concertation est fondée sur une étude
d'impact approfondie soumise au
Parlement
voilà un document qui était clair et qui
fixait les choses malheureusement il
faut bien le reconnaître votre
prédécesseur on a pu tenu compte vous
n'y êtes pour rien je le dis bien
volontiers assez tribune mais nous avons
pas rencontré un écho extraordinaire à
ce moment-là et notamment l'occasion du
texte de 2018 dommage dommage parce que
en 2021 la situation s'est malgré tout
aggravée
l'Agora de la justice que nous avions
organisé que le président l'archet avait
organisé en septembre avait fait état de
16 propositions et notamment pour
poursuivre toujours pareil la mise à
niveau des effectifs dans les
juridictions comblés en priorité les
vacances de poste de greffier réévaluer
les besoins des magistrats
professionnels au regard des réformes
intervenus augmenter le nombre de
ficiers de police judiciaires rendent
plus attractif ces fonctions et
renforcer leur formation continue
procéder à l'évaluation réalise de toute
évolution législative et réglementaire
en matière de justice et dressé à bilan
rigoureux
nous étions déjà dans la période
postokovide qui avait révélé à un
certain nombre de carences fortes dans
le fonctionnement du dispositif et puis
arrivera un sondage au moment de cet
Agora où on constatera que 53% de nos
concitoyens déclarent ne pas faire
confiance à notre justice qu'il
considère trop longs trop lente pardon
et en conséquence ne la saisissent pas
en cas de litige selon vraiment en
dernier recours
c'est constat-là ont donné naissance
dans un contexte particulier aux États
généraux
malheureusement une pétition de nombreux
magistrats 3000 signataires en fait on
aurait 7000 nous dit-on
et une suscitation forte auprès du
gouvernement et vous organisez les stats
généraux de la justice
finalement ces états généraux rendant
leur rapport au mois de juillet dernier
on conforté j'avais presque dire
malheureusement
ce qui avait été constaté déjà en 2017
et finalement
s'engageant dans les principes qui
avaient déjà été élaborés ont réaffirmé
qu'il fallait outre une remise à niveau
des moyens humains et matériels une
réforme systémique de la justice
bien sûr un des points particuliers qui
ressort c'est la simplification de la
procédure pénale mais n'oublions pas mes
chers collègues que la procédure pénale
n'est qu'une partie évidemment
extrêmement importante elle touche à nos
libertés mais que la procédure civile
est encore plus en souffrance en réalité
elle est la justice du quotidien la
justice de tous les jours de celle de
celles et ceux qui n'iront pas en prison
mais qui ont besoin de récupérer un
loyer une propriété de discuter un
conflit de voisinage x ou y voir une
dette et dans ces conditions là elle est
absolument essentielle alors
monsieur le ministre
nous devons dire honnêtement que c'est
un budget qu'il faut saluer
c'est un budget important puisque pour
la troisième c'est la troisième hausse
consécutive de 8% et un budget qui
atteindra un peu plus de 9 milliards
d'euros ce qui n'est pas inintéressant
mais
notons que ça représente une
augmentation de 40 % depuis 2017 je fais
un petit calcul rapide exactement ma
fournisseur et je trouve que on rattrape
les choses disons-le on rattrape ce que
nous avions nous-mêmes constaté et nous
devons le dire néanmoins
quelques points nous interroge moi sur
le fond que sur la capacité à faire
création de 10000 emplois
supplémentaires sur quinquennat très
bien cependant
il faudra sécuriser les embauches
annoncer de 1500 magistrats
supplémentaires sur 5 ans sans
naturellement sacrifier la qualité du
recrutement je pense que tout le monde y
est attaché on aura un problème qui est
un problème de capacité à recruter un
tel volume de magistrats capacité de
l'école sont là mais bon si ce n'est pas
impossible et puis la formation de 500
auditeurs de justice et de 1000
greffiers par an ce qui impliquera
d'importance d'aménagements mais qui
permettra naturellement pour les
greffiers et aussi il faut pas les
oublier les surveillants pénitentiaires
et les assistants pour compléter les
équipes autour des magistrats
j'entendais tout à l'heure qu'il fallait
regretter les contractuels qui avaient
été pris je dois dire qu'ils ont été
sincèrement utiles les magistrats que
nous rencontrons tous dans les
juridictions le confirme ils ont même
demandé à ce que vous les gardiez à ce
qu'ils puissent les garder de les garder
d'ailleurs donc attention à ce type de
propos la magistrature a besoin de
confiance elle a besoin de
mots qu'il a rassurent j'allais presque
dire et de moyens qu'ils soient pérennes
pour lui permettre de continuer son
travail donc nous aurons peut-être
quelques difficultés à recruter des
surveillants pénitentiaires il faudra
bien trouver le moyen d'attirer dans
cette profession et de fidéliser vous
avez revalorisé les rémunérations à
hauteur de 117 millions d'euros non pas
pour chaque magistrat il leur a aimé
sans doute mais pour l'ensemble des
magistrats 50 millions pour les
fonctionnaires et 10 millions pour les
greffiers vous avez rappelé les 15000
places de prison vous savez qu'ici
à la construction de ces 15000 places de
prison combien de fois avons-nous dit à
cette tribune ou dans d'autres cénacles
que ils avaient été annoncés il y a
plusieurs années qui doivent être eu
fait qu'ils ne sont pas faits mais qu'il
faudra bien les faire
je pense que c'est absolument nécessaire
ça répond d'abord à deux objectifs 1
essayer d'arriver à un moment ou un
autre à l'enseignement individuel autant
que faire ce peu
de répondre à une politique pénale qui
doit être complète à savoir
l'incarcération pas seulement il y a
d'autres lieux de privatives de liberté
qu'il est présent pure et Dieu les lieux
semi liberté sont nécessaires c'est en
réalité la complémentarité qui compte et
là-dessus de chez le ministre nous
serons en tous les cas susney vigilants
attentifs à ceux qui pourra être fait au
total se rattrapage et bien il était
absolument nécessaire et nous devons
tout de même vous le dire reste un point
particulier qui
qui est je lis pas passionnelle
n'exagéront rien mais qui est un point
important à la commission des lois qui
est la numérisation
c'est vraiment le sujet sur lequel
certains diront c'est un marronnier mais
il faut bien reconnaître ce que ça reste
un point faible
madame Belloubet elle va dire 2018 c'est
le cœur du réacte très bien on était
d'accord pour le partager avec elle vous
avez mis de l'argent
c'est de ces deux derniers budgets même
dans ces trois derniers budgets
importants la question aujourd'hui se
pose moins de l'argent que de la mise en
œuvre et que de la capacité à pouvoir
aller vite et répondre rapidement à ce
qu'attend à la fois les magistrats pas
seulement naturellement les greffiers
enfin on les en réalité tous les
personnels de justice pour que les
choses soient enfin remises à niveau je
ne dis pas que nous étions à la
Préhistoire mais tout de même nous avons
un sacré retard
à l'égard dans ce type de dans un
ministère régalien extrêmement important
alors que d'autres finalement ont réussi
cette réforme et le soin de vue là
refonder la maîtrise d'ouvrage des
applications nécessaires renforcer la
place numérique au secrétaire général et
dans les autres directions du ministère
est indispensable et enfin que notre
justice soit équipée j'allais dire
dignement n'est pas le mot mais
efficacement afin de rendre le service
que nous attendons
monsieur le ministre chers collègues je
n'ai pas l'intention d'être beaucoup
plus long si ce n'est pour rappeler un
point particulier
nous avons ce matin évoqué le budget de
la sécurité
du singulièrement la locmin les moyens
nouveaux les 15 milliards qui sont
passés qui sont imprévus la volonté de
renforcer nos services de police
judiciaire sécurité publique bien je ne
rentre pas dans le détail ça n'est pas
l'objet du soir mais
si les choses vont au bout nous aurons
un service des services de police qui
devrait être extrêmement performants et
productif
et la production si vous me permettez
cette expression et bien de voir être
absorbé par notre justice et qu'en
réalité ce qui compte c'est l'attelage
complet
et donc il faudra veiller je pense assez
rapidement à ce que tout cela fonctionne
bien ensemble pour ne pas qu'on se
retrouve dans des situations absolument
ubuesque qu'on aurait des arrestations
importantes ou des procédures engagées
importantes et les magistrats en
difficulté pour pouvoir réagir le mal
serait pire que tout et chacun sait ici
que les choses pourraient s'enflammer
facilement deuxième point et j'en
terminerai par là Monsieur le Ministre
ces véritablement la nécessité
ces efforts budgétaires ne doivent pas
être des efforts de conjoncture ils ne
sont pas je le crois mais vraiment des
efforts structurels il faut doter notre
justice de moyens pérenne qui permettent
évidemment les autres réformes qu'il
faudra t'engager parmi ces signes nous
attendons votre texte il viendra n'en
doutons pas voilà la simplification de
la procédure pénale sur des évolutions
évidemment en matière civile en tous les
cas sur une adaptation de notre système
judiciaire qui est au service de
l'ensemble des habitants et de nos
concitoyens le groupe LR que je
représente ce soir à cette tribune et
pour qui je prends la parole suivra les
avis favorables de nos rapporteurs sur
l'ensemble de cette mission je vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président
la parole est maintenant Monsieur Alain
Marc pour le groupe les indépendants
pour 5 minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux mes chers collègues
cette année encore nous nous réjouissons
devant le budget de la justice et
progresser de 8%. elle en a bien besoin
après avoir été délaissé pendant des
années au point que les conditions
d'exercice des professionnels du droit
sont devenus insoutenables au point
aussi que nous concitoyens ont perdu
confiance en elle en juillet dernier 70%
des Français considérés que la justice
fonctionne mal lorsque l'on sait de rôle
essentiel que celle-ci joue dans notre
société aussi bien pour la cohésion
nationale que pour la vie de notre
démocratie nous ne pouvions que nous en
inquiéter il était urgent d'inverser la
tendance
le budget de la justice progresse ainsi
de 26% entre 2020 et 2023 comme la
commission nous notons la place
prépondérante de l'administration
pénitentiaire dans ce budget la
construction de places de prison est une
nécessité pour assurer le respect de
notre politique pénale c'est également
un impératif pour éliminer la
surpopulation carcérale et permettre à
notre pays de respecter ses engagements
en matière de droits humains des
juridictions judiciaires ont également
un impérieux besoin de crédit les
magistrats sont débordés et ils sont
depuis longtemps un nombre insuffisant
difficile dans ces conditions de juger
les affaires dans un délai raisonnable
le projet de budget pour 2023 prévoit de
renforcement significatif des effectifs
avec la création de 1220 postes nets
dont 200 magistrats nous ne saluons
autre mesure très attendue de ce projet
des magistrats judiciaires vont
bénéficier d'une revalorisation
indemnitaire de 1000 euros brut cette
revalorisation nous paraît nécessaire
pour maintenir l'attractivité de la
fonction et le contrib gouvernement à
mettre fin à une inégalité entre
magistrats judiciaire et magistrat
administratif ou financier qui ne se
justifie nullement il est grand temps
d'y mettre en termes le monde judiciaire
ne se limite pas au magistrats bien
qu'ils en soi la pièce maîtresse les
greffiers sont des éléments très
importants plusieurs dispositions de ce
budget leur sont destinés ils sont ainsi
concernés par le renforcement de leurs
effectifs et une revalorisation
indemnitaire
ce n'est pas à vous monsieur le garde
des sceaux que nous apprendrons le rôle
essentiel des avocats auxiliaire de
justice ils assurent la défense de nos
concitoyens et se battent pour faire
respecter leurs droits et libertés cette
mission est encore plus nécessaire
auprès de ceux de nos concitoyens qui
sont les plus démunis le budget de cette
année prolonge la dynamique de
l'augmentation de la rétribution des
avocats et de juridictionnelle il ne
s'agit pas ici d'intérêt catégoriels
mais bien de l'accès aux droits de
l'accès au juge nous nous félicitons
donc de cette augmentation le volet
numérique que vient évoquer de évoquer
François Noel buffet constitue aussi un
chantier important comme beaucoup
d'autres le ministère de la Justice se
fait face à des difficultés dans la
numérisation de ces activités nous
souhaitons tous que l'augmentation du
budget de la justice produisent ses
effets le plus rapidement possible les
délais de jugement sont encore beaucoup
trop longs
plus de nain pour une affaire civile
deux ans pour un divorce ou encore à
plus de quatre ans pour une affaire
pénale nous ne pouvons pas nous en
satisfaire la justice prend du temps
mettant qu'elle n'est pas passée
l'application du droit et comme
suspendue les augmentations de budget
comme celle de ces dernières années
contribue à améliorer la justice de
notre pays et le contribue à redonner
confiance en nos institutions à nos
citoyens du moins nous l'espérons nul
doute que les défis à venir
nécessiteront de poursuivre cette
trajectoire l'ensemble de notre groupe
votera donc en faveur de l'adoption des
crédits de cette mission
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Marie-Pierre de la
Gontrie pour le groupe socialiste pour 4
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs
mes chers collègues
je ne vous étonnerai pas à ce stade de
la discussion générale puisque je suis
la dernière intervenante de vous dire
que mon groupe comme chacun sur ses
bancs salut l'augmentation de de crédit
prévu pour cette mission même si j'y
reviendrai nous aurons des questions à
poser concernant la réalité de cette
augmentation donc beaucoup de choses ont
été déjà été dites et je souhaiterais
simplement souligner quelques points ou
poser quelques questions tout d'abord
sur la méthode le comité des états
généraux de la justice avaient affirmé
dans son rapport le besoin de ce soit en
budgétaire mais il précisait aussi la
nécessité de repenser de façon
systémique et articuler l'institution
judiciaire en soulignant qu'avant de
poser la question des moyens il fallait
clarifier les objectifs à signer à la
justice comment avez-vous appréhendé
cette démarche en deuxième lieu notre
groupe se s'interroge ou apprécie
l'effectivité de cette augmentation au
regard du contexte inflationniste chacun
ici depuis le début de cette discussion
salut l'augmentation et il faut le faire
d'autant qu'elle est répétée mais en
lisant l'excellent rapport de la
commission des finances de notre
collègue Lefebvre j'ai pu relever que
cette augmentation serait en
neuroconstant de 3,2 % là où elle est de
cette en valeur et donc il faut le
souligner pouvez-vous par ailleurs nous
éclairer sur vos prévisions d'exécution
au regard de la sous-exécution qui a été
constatée dans le domaine de
l'investissement dont on vous budget
précédent après dans notre groupe nous
avons une divergence d'appréciation
concernant votre vision un peu
sécuritaire de la justice et qui est
poursuit la lignée budgétaire des
précédentes années je ne vais pas
rappeler le nombre de magistrats ou de
personnels de justice insuffisant en
France par rapport aux autres pays
je vais néanmoins pour mon groupe saluer
les créations d'emplois saluer la
revalorisation salariale même si elle ne
résout pas le problème de l'attractivité
de des fonctions elle est évidemment
très importante nous avons noté aussi la
hausse du budget dédié au bracelet anti
rapprochement sans savoir très
exactement mais vous nous le direz
peut-être si cela est dû simplement au
changement de prestataire ou s'il s'agit
d'un renforcement du dispositif alors
au-delà de cela nous allons présenter
des amendements un amendement partagé
sur l'ensemble des bancs me semble-t-il
concernant l'aide juridictionnelle vous
savez que nous soutenons la proposition
qui avait été faite il y a plusieurs
années maintenant de du rapport Perben
pour la revalorisation de la
juridictionnelle pour l'unité des
valeurs à 42 euros
inutile vous ancienne avocat de
souligner à quel point c'est nécessaire
pour l'accès au droit des justiciables
en difficulté financière mais surtout
nous allons présenter un amendement en
cette Journée internationale pour
l'élimination de la violence faite aux
femmes concernant l'instauration de la
juridiction spécialisée en charge des
violences sexuelles intrafamiliales et
conjugales nous avons déjà par le passé
fait cette proposition nous continuerons
inlassablement de vous apporter vous le
savez notre modèle c'est le modèle
espagnol je rappelle car j'ai compris
que vous doutiez de son efficacité que
depuis 2004 25% de féminicides en moins
en Espagne 56
000 femmes protégées par an deux fois
plus de condamnation qu'en France et un
magistrat sur 3 et formé à cette matière
extrêmement particulière donc sur ce
point qui n'est pas un point très
coûteux vous en êtes convenu lors de la
commission des lois nous souhaitons
nonobstant le fait qu'une mission sur
son contour soit prévu que vous nous
précisiez vous ambitions budgétaires
sous ces différentes questions le groupe
mais je crois que Jean-Pierre Sueur a
failli pouvoir le dire tout à l'heure
s'apprête à voter favorablement cette
mission
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice pour 15 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois monsieur le rapporteur spécial
monsieur les rapporteurs pour avis
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
le projet de budget que j'ai l'honneur
de venir vous présenter aujourd'hui
devrait permettre si vous le votez
d'autoriser une nouvelle hausse de plus
de 8% en 2023 au profit de notre justice
sont ainsi 710 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui viendrait abonder en
2023 service public de la justice qui
frôlerait ainsi les 10 milliards d'euros
pour l'année 2023 d'aucun diront
peut-être que ceci n'est jamais assez
mais je veux dire que
c'est plus que cela n'a jamais été
nous poursuivons les hausses sur ce
quinquennat et j'insiste tous les
acteurs du ministère
bénéficieront très directement et très
concrètement de ces hausses
plus 9 % pour les services judiciaires
pour atteindre
3,39 milliards d'euros pour 2023
plus de 7% de hausse de crédit consacrée
à l'administration pénitentiaire soit un
budget de
3,91 milliards d'euros pour 2023 une
hausse de plus de 10% en bénéfices de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
atteignant donc 917 atteignants donc
pardon 917 millions d'euros pour
2023 si l'on fait le bilan de les formes
budgétaires consacrées à la justice
depuis mon arrivée
sont près de 4 milliards d'euros de
crédit supplémentaires passant ainsi de
7,6 milliards d'euros en 2020 à 9,6
milliards d'euros en 2023 sont ainsi
venus renforcer les moyens justice
ça représente une hausse de plus de 26%
du budget en trois ans et plus de 40% si
l'on prend comme point de départ le
début du premier quinquennat du
président de la République pour mémoire
le budget de la justice en 2017
s'élevait à 6,9 milliards d'euros
cette nouvelle hausse budgétaire vient
donc comme une confirmation de la
priorité
plurie annuelle donnée à la justice au
sein de la politique gouvernementale
cette hausse confirme notre cap
poursuivre le rattrapage de de 30 ans
d'abandon de la justice
et mettre en oeuvre les recommandations
issues des étages généraux de la justice
à ce propos
il faut souligner que bien sûr il y a la
question des moyens
mais il n'y a pas que la question des
moyens
il faut également que nous allions vers
une simplification
de la procédure civile de la procédure
pénale
et notre objectif il est commun je le
sais c'est une justice plus proche plus
rapide bien sûr plus efficace je
n'encerai dans quelques jours le plan
d'action issus des États généraux et je
viendrai bien sûr le présenter à votre
commission des Lois
premièrement mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs l'efficacité de la justice
tient tout d'abord
aux hommes et aux femmes qui font preuve
d'un engagement quotidien
afin de soutenir nos agences c'est un
plan de recrutement de 10 000 emplois
supplémentaires qui sera mis en place
d'ici 2027
donc
des emplois ont juridiction et 605 ont
d'ores et déjà été pérennisé au titre de
la justice de proximité à la mi 2022
c'est 10000 recrutements seront répartis
finement année après année en fonction
des besoins qui nous remontent du
terrain mais également bien sûr des
besoins opérationnels néanmoins je peux
d'ores et déjà sanctuariser la création
de 1500 postes de magistrats
de 1500 postes de greffiers
supplémentaires sur tout le quinquennat
afin de renforcer les effectifs en
juridiction ça représente un rythme
d'embauche qui est deux fois plus
important que sur le premier quinquennat
s'agissant de 2023 et pour être très
précis c'est le chiffre de
22503 personnels supplémentaires et
c'est ce nombre qui sera recruté pour la
justice
par contraste avec 2022
720 création d'emplois a été prévue cela
signifie donc que nous triplerons en
2023 le rythme des recrutements en un an
c'est 2253 personnels seront répartis de
la façon suivante
1220 pour la justice judiciaire dont 200
magistrats 191 greffiers 809 pour
l'administration pénitentiaire 92 pour
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
le reste soit 132 personnels bénéficiera
à la coordination de la politique
publique de la justice en plus de ces
2253 emplois supplémentaires 60 sont
prévus pour nos opérateurs
deuxièmement mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs pour assurer ce niveau inédit
de recrutement je souhaite renforcer
encore l'attractivité des métiers de
justice par des revalorisations
salariales et à cet effet le budget 2023
permettra une fois encore de hausser les
crédits obtenus au titre des mesures
catégorielles atteignant ainsi 60
millions d'euros en 2023 afin de
favoriser de revaloriser les
professionnels de ce ministère soit un
doublement de l'enveloppe par rapport à
2022 concernant les magistrats vous le
savez revalorisation inédite sera mise
en place à compter du 1er octobre 2023 à
hauteur de 1000 euros par mois en
moyenne soit une hausse de plus de 16%
en un an de la masse salariale des
magistrats la conséquence est direct
demain un jeune magistrat sortant de
l'ENM débutera sa carrière après de 3000
euros net par mois
concernant les fonctionnaires 2023 sera
encore une année historique avec une
enveloppe catégorielle de 50 millions
d'euros cette enveloppe permettra
d'améliorer la tractivité de nos métiers
et de développer et de fidéliser les
compétences concernant les greffiers les
forts inédits consacrés à la
revalorisation indemnitaire des
greffiers et directeur de service de
greffe sera poursuivi et plus de 10
millions d'euros seront consacrés à
cette fin en 2023 au total au total
c'est une augmentation de 12% dont
bénéficieront les personnels de greffe
entre 2021 et 2023 par ailleurs j'ai
demandé au directeur des services
judiciaires d'engager une réflexion sur
une réforme du statut des greffier
concernant les personnels relevant des
corps spécifiques de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse 7 millions
d'euros seront consacrés cette année à
des revalorisations indemnitaires
concernant les surveillants
pénitentiaires nous finalisons en 2023
la mesure de revalorisation de
l'indemnité pour charge pénitentiaire
qui est passé de 1400 euros à 1869 euros
sur trois ans les surveillants
pénitentiaires ont bénéficié en 2022
d'une réforme importante de leur statut
et de leur rémunération la fusion des
grades de surveillants et de brigadier a
permis de simplifier la carrière des
agents et de revaloriser la rémunération
notamment en début et en fin de carrière
comme je l'ai toujours dit cette réforme
est une première étape des travaux
seront engagés dès le début de l'année
2023 avec bien sûr les organisations
syndicales pour travailler à une
revalorisation d'envergure de leur
statut et de leur rémunération qui sera
mise en oeuvre dans les années suivantes
nous devons en effet pour ouvrir les
établissements pénitentiaires du plan
15000 nous donnait tous les moyens pour
recruter plus et dans de meilleures
conditions pour fidéliser bien sûr les
agents qui exercent des missions
nécessaires mais si difficile et nous le
savons tous enfin pour nos corps
d'encadrement qu'il soit directeur des
services de grève directeur d'insertion
de probation directeur de service à la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse ou
directeur des services pénitentiaires
près de 10 millions d'euros seront
consacrés cette année à une
revalorisation de leur régime
indemnitaire mais également indiciaire
troisièmement mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ces crédit permettront au
ministère d'achever le plan de
construction des 15000 places de prison
supplémentaires voulues par le Président
de la République ce plan permettra
d'augmenter la capacité carcérale de 60
000 à plus de
75000 places
depuis mon arrivée à la tête de ce
ministère
j'y suis engagé pleinement
en ce moment même
ce sont 18
opérations qui sont en chantier dans
toute la France et 10 seront finalisés
en 2023 en particulier à Avignon numéro
3 Lavaux d'une façon générale ce sont la
moitié des établissements qui seront
opérationnels en 2024 sur la
cinquantaine de chantiers que compte le
plan 15000 le rythme des livraisons va
maintenant s'accélérer jusqu'en 2027 car
l'ensemble des terrains sont désormais
identifiés
c'est d'ailleurs à cet échéance de 2027
que je vous propose de projet le
moratoire sur l'impératif en cellulement
individuel c'est dans ce cadre que le
gouvernement émettra un avis favorable à
l'amendement proposé par Monsieur le
Rapporteur spécial Lefèvre consistant à
remettre deux rapports au Parlement en
2025 et 2027 rapport qui permettront
d'informer en toute transparence et en
responsabilité le Parlement de l'état
d'avancement du programme immobilier
pénitentiaire et de son impact sur le
taux de placement en cellule
individuelle quatrièmement je souhaite
moderniser et agrandir l'immobilier
juridictionnelle c'est indispensable si
l'on veut permettre l'accueil des
renforts humains qui sont attendus dans
les années à venir c'est 502 millions
d'euros d'autorisation d'engagement et 2
entre 9 millions d'euros en crédit de
paiement immobilier qui sont prévus en
2023 ça permettra en outre de poursuivre
des opérations majeures engagées lors du
quinquennat précédent je pense notamment
au palais de justice de Lille de l'île
de la Cité de Bayonne d'autres chantiers
et de poursuivre les études des projets
de Cayenne
qcmo moulin Nancy Nantes Perpignan de
l'ancienne nouvelle opérations
immobilières comme à Argentan Chartres
Colmar Saint-Brieuc ou bien encore
Verdun enfin
cinquièmement et dernièrement
permettez-moi de mettre en exergue
certains efforts budgétaires l'enveloppe
de crédit consacrée aux dépenses de
frais de justice se rapportaient à 660
millions d'euros soit une hausse de 12
millions d'euros les crédits
d'investissement informatique seront
portés à 195 millions d'euros dans le
cadre de la poursuite de la mise en
œuvre du plan de transformation
numérique du ministère les crédits
dédiés à l'aide juridictionnelle
constitueront de continueront pardon de
croître en 2023 pour atteindre
641 millions d'euros soit plus de 26
millions d'euros en une année
parallèlement l'aide aux victimes sera
portée à 43 millions soit une hausse de
7% et au sein de cette enveloppe
16,1 millions d'euros seront dédiés aux
violences intrafamiliales marquant un
double du budget vif annuel qui était de
8 millions d'euros à mon arrivée en 2020
la justice est à la croisée des chemins
bien sûr
délaissés pendant près de trois
décennies elle fait l'objet depuis 5 ans
d'un renforcement massif de près de 4,7
milliards d'euros traduction
de la volonté claire du président et de
la première ministre mais également la
mienne
de considérer la justice pour ce qu'elle
est une institution
qui fonde le pacte social
il vous revient en tant que
parlementaire de poursuivre sur cette
voie du renforcement de notre justice
ou de bifirquer vers les réflexes des
décennies passées mais je pense que
personne n'en a envie sous dotation
effet d'affichage sans lendemain courte
termisme à quoi bonisme etc etc etc on
répare pas vous le savez bien 30 ans
d'abandon budgétaire humain politique en
un claquement de doigts et la route est
longue bien sûr mais j'espère que le
Sénat qui accorde à la justice une
grande importance
tout comme ces commissions des lois et
des Finances sera à nos côtés pour voter
cette nouvelle hausse de 8% et
poursuivra à nos côtés sur le chemin de
la restauration massive d'une justice
que l'on veut tous rapide efficace
proche de nos concitoyens la justice de
qualité que nous appelons tous de nos
vœux pour ceux qui la font vivre mais
aussi pour ceux qu'elle sert tous nos
compatriotes
merci monsieur le ministre
je vous rappelle mes chers collègues que
pour cette mission la Conférence des
Présidents fixé la durée maximale de la
discussion à trois heures en conséquence
l'examen de cette mission pourrait se
prolonger jusqu'à 20h30
[Musique]
si par malheur ça n'était pas terminé à
20h30 la fin de l'étude de la mission
serait reportée à la semaine prochaine
qu'est-ce qui se passe ce matin
c'est à votre gré madame mais je vous en
saurais très gré effectivement allez
examen des amendements le 727 du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
encore blessés par les mots que je viens
d'entendre vous avez dit si par malheur
monsieur le président
bon c'est un amendement du Gouvernement
effectivement qui vise à rétablir les
crédits supprimés sur le programme
justice judiciaire de la mission justice
au cours des débats sur le PLF 2023 à
l'Assemblée nationale compte tenu des
mouvements de crédit opérés par
l'amendement de
1906 ces ouvertures de crédit sont
considérées comme des charges de
fonctionnement telles que définis au
premièrement la quatrièmement et
sixièmement du 1 de l'article 5 de la lo
LF
avis de la commission sur le rapporteur
spécial
alors je signale tout d'abord à
l'ensemble de mes collègues que cet
amendement a été déposé ce midi donc
après la réunion de la commission ce
sera donc un avis personnel que je vais
exprimer sur cet amendement qui ne fait
que rétablir les crédits du programme
justice judiciaire le texte est d'abordé
par le gouvernement et sur lequel il a
engagé sa responsabilité en application
d'article 49 alinéa 3 la Constitution
intégré en effet un amendement
réhaussant les crédits en faveur du
dispositif téléphone grave danger mais
sans lever le gage j'avais d'ailleurs
dans mon rapport budgétaire appelé le
gouvernement à lever ce gage en
rétablissant les crédits du programme
justice judiciaire je ne peux donc être
que favorable à ce moment qui suit ma
recommandation
merci je vais mettre au voile 727 du
gouvernement avec un avis favorable de
la commission qui est pour
quiconque il est adopté quatre
amendements discussion communes d'abord
deux identiques le 68 n'est pas défendu
le 307 madame de La Gontrie il est
défendu
le 274 madame Carrère
défendu le 239 monsieur
je vais quand même le définir puisque
c'est un amendement qui vise à
revaloriser le montant l'unité de valeur
de l'aide duel à 42 euros voilà
c'est avis de la commission sur le
rapporteur sur ces trois amants
alors je demande le retrait des
amendements concernés qui viennent
d'être défendu qui propose d'augmenter
les crédits d'aide juridiction
juridictionnelle pardon il s'agit il me
semble davantage d'amendement d'appel
pour attirer l'attention du gouvernement
sur la faiblesse du montant relatif de
l'unité valeur je partage de ce point de
vue les préoccupations de mes collègues
monsieur le ministre les avocats nous
confient que dans le près de la moitié
des cas les Retribution au titre de
l'aide juridictionnelle n'est pas
suffisante pour couvrir les frais qu'ils
engagent par dossier le rapport de
Dominique Perben sur l'avenir de la
profession d'avocat avait à cet égard
recommandé de rehausser le montant
d'unité de valeur à 40 euros alors deux
raisons qui justifient la position de
demande de retrait il faut d'abord noter
que la revalorisation du montant de l'UV
a fortement progressé ces dernières
années avec il faut bien le mentionner
un coup certain pour les finances
publiques cependant ce montant n'était
que de 26,5 euros en 2016 il est
désormais à 36 euros depuis le lot de
finance pour 2022 il y a donc eu un
rattrapage sur cette période bien qu'il
puisse encore il semble encore
insuffisant dans certains cas monsieur
le ministre pourra sans doute nous pour
le prochain budget de nouvelles pistes
d'amélioration
et surtout s'ils étaient adoptés ces
amendements augmenteraient certes le
budget de la juridictionnelle mais le
permettrait absolument pas de
revaloriser le montant l'unité de valeur
pour les avocats leur porter concrète et
donc limité demande de retrait ou à
défaut défavorable avis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre sur ces trois
amendements
identiques c'est un avis évidemment
identique monsieur le Président que je
veux exprimer je rappelais quand même
que le budget qui vous est présenté
inscrit un budget consacré à la vie de
641 millions que comme cela vient de
vous être rappelé par rapport à 2022 ça
représente une hausse de plus de 26
millions mais surtout depuis 2021 ça
représente une hausse de 157 millions
d'euros soit plus 32%. alors à la
question qui m'est posée est-ce que nous
ferons plus dans les prochains budgets
bien sûr que c'est ma volonté et je vais
vous dire autre chose parmi les choses
qui sont et les réponses qui sont
envisagées à la suite des États généraux
il y a davantage d'amiable et donc de
médiation et donc d'intervention du
barreau et il faudra donc dans ces
conditions là bien sûr que l'on permette
aux avocats
voilà comment je l'exprime à cet instant
de préférer la médiation et l'amiable
plutôt que le procès et naturellement
ils vont regarder ce qu'il gagne et si
c'est le procès qui paie davantage que
la médiation on ira moins vers le procès
c'est bien naturel on dira moins vers la
médiation pardon pardon oui merci Madame
le sénatrice de rectifier le propos mais
vous l'aviez parfaitement suivi nous
dans ces conditions je ne puis que être
sur l'imposition qui vient d'être vient
d'être exprimée tu demandes de retrait
ou alors avis défavorable
merci madame de la ganterie
oui je crois que
ce n'est absolument pas en tout cas
concernant le 307 ce n'est pas du tout
un amendement d'appel c'est pas parce
que le progrès a été fait qu'il est
suffisant il s'agit enfin je suis le
ministre je suis presque gêné de le
souligner puisque dans cette hémicycle
vous êtes un de ceux qui savent le plus
ce que je vais énoncer mais il s'agit de
population qui n'ont pas accès aux
droits il s'agit de professionnelle de
la justice qui eux-mêmes se détournent
de plus en plus de la GIE parce que il
ne s'y retrouve pas donc si on veut
réellement que les Français puissent
exercer
le droit de manière
satisfaisante il faut nécessairement en
passer par là et pour le coup je vous
trouve sévère avec nos anciens confrères
je ne crois pas qu'il s'orienteront vers
le procès plus que vers la médiation
parce que ce serait mieux rémunéré parce
que de toute façon nous le savons bien
la J est quand même
peut rémunérer donc ça n'est jamais
quelque chose d'intéressant donc encore
une fois vous le voyez sur tous les
bancs nous souhaitons cette
revalorisation et donc ce n'était pas un
amendement d'appel et nous souhaitons
qu'il soit voté
merci oui madame Carrère
très bien je ne vois pas d'autres prises
de parole je vais donc mettre au voie
d'abord le 307 avec deux avis
défavorables qui pour
attendez 1 2 3
merci
qui est contre
il est adopté et il fait tomber les
autres amendements
je passe au 306 monsieur le testeur
tue le président monsieur le garde des
sceaux mes chers collègues comme vous
avez fait preuve d'un zèle monsieur le
Président tout à l'heure très
remarquable en main dérompant au milieu
d'une phrase ce qui est démontre votre
grand attachement à la loi du
chronomètre pourtant mes phrases restent
raisonnables je ne me compare pas à
Marcel Proust vous le savez bien donc
vous usciez plus me laisser finir ma
phrase que disait la fin de la phrase
chacun s'interroge sur ce sujet et bien
elle disait je vais vous rassurer elle
disait que ce que monsieur le garde des
sauces c'est très bien qu'il ne suffit
pas de construire de nouvelles prisons
pour régler le problème de la
surpopulation pénitentiaire mais que dès
maintenant
les états généraux de la justice
demandent une régulation et cette
régulation naturellement elle doit être
compatible avec les choix qui sont faits
par les juges les magistrats mais il est
possible premièrement de faire très
attention aux courtes peines qui ont
souvent des effets négatifs
deuxièmement de développer les
alternatives à la détention qui sont
aussi des peines et qui sont efficaces
et troisièmement de travailler sur les
aménagements de peine de cela vous
n'avez nullement parlé monsieur le garde
des sceaux dans votre propos mais
j'espère que vous souscrirez à ces
orientations qui éviteront que l'on
puisse être à nouveau jugés pour
indignité il est possible que l'on
traite mieux la question
parler alternatives et par les
aménagements de peine donc nous croyons
que c'est là une absolue nécessité et
c'est pourquoi nous avons déposé
monsieur le Président cette amendement
vous voyez là je termine juste ah oui
j'ai fait attention parce que sans ça
je demande le retrait de cette
amendement
[Musique]
notre collègue vous ne parlez
d'importance de soutenir l'agence du
travail d'intérêt général j'ai interrogé
les directions du ministère de la
Justice sur ce point dans le cadre de
mes travaux ils m'ont confirmé que les
30000 postes seraient atteints dès 2023
encore faut-il après que les places
soient occupés mais cela relève moins de
l'administration pénitentiaire que la
décision des magistrats la
diversification des postes a également
tendance à s'accroître ce qui ne peut
être que positif pour l'insertion des
détenus la direction d'administration
pénitentiaire souhaite également
redynamiser les partenariats avec les
régions notamment pour la formation
professionnelle et davantage renforcer
le lien entre travail et formation
professionnelle en lien avec les besoins
de main d'oeuvre des bassins d'emploi
des territoires régionaux donc demande
de retrait ou à défaut défavorable
avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre le même monsieur le président
je suis saisi sur cette amendement d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
les républicains
je vous rappelle que la ville de la
commission est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement
le scrutin public est ouvert
on a voté le scrutin avec l'eau
votre temps 344 pour l'amendement 92
contre 252 l'amendement n'est pas adopté
je passe au 308 madame de La Gontrie
ah pardon madame la Présidente
du groupe socialiste vise à créer une
juridiction spécialisée dans la lutte
contre les violences commises au sein de
la famille à l'encontre des femmes et
des enfants c'est amendement me permet
d'interroger le garde des sourds et lui
dire mon inquiétude
je sais que le président Macron avait
dans sa campagne pris un engagement en
faveur de la création de cette
juridiction spécialisée je sais que la
Ministre chargée d'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes il est attaché
qu'elle y travaille que deux
parlementaires ont en mission ont été
nommés aujourd'hui le président de la
République était à Dijon j'imagine qu'il
n'est pas l'addhion uniquement pour
rencontrer son ami de mère de Dijon un
25 novembre j'imagine qu'il avait aussi
des annonces à faire en matière de lutte
contre les violences faite aux femmes et
aux enfants et nous attendions une
annonce en particulier sur la
juridiction spécialisée donc c'est
amendement va nous permettre monsieur le
garde des sceaux que vous nous
confirmiez bien l'engagement du
président de la République la mise en
place rapide de cette juridiction
spécialisée car nous en avons besoin pas
besoin pourquoi nous en avons besoin
nous avons identifié les violences
faites aux femmes avant qu'elles
quittent le domicile nous avons
identifié le parcours de sortie du
domicile éviction du conjoint violent et
où mis à l'abri de la femme et ses
enfants et puis il y a un deuxième un
troisième parcours derrière qui est
celui des violences postes séparations
les violences dans lesquelles les hommes
qui ont perdu la pleine propriété la
possession de leur femme continue de
développer leur vindique à l'encontre de
leur ex-épouse par l'intermédiaire des
enfants et ces violences là elles se
nouent dans le cabinet du jeu aux
affaires familiales parfois elles vont
jusqu'au juge pour enfants elles sont
parallèles avec des actions des plaintes
déposées devant la justice pénale et
nous avons là des trois deux ou trois
juridictions qui parallèlement traite de
la même affaire satanent mutuellement
les unes des autres chacune tient
l'autre en l'état et les femmes
et les femmes sont coincées nous avons
besoin de cette juridiction spécialisée
merci
avis de la commission
alors je demande le retrait de cet
amendement en fait la position que
j'exprime elle est conforme à celle
qu'il a été déjà exprimée par mes
collègues de la commission des lois et
par le Sénat notamment lors de l'examen
du projet de loi d'orientation de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur je reprendrai ici
l'argumentaire qui avait été développé
alors ce n'est pas sans doute par le
biais d'un amendement que nous pouvons
proposer une telle réforme de notre
organisation judiciaire même si là pour
mérite d'aborder ce sujet extrêmement
délicat comme vous venez de le faire
d'importantes questions de procédure de
compétences de moyens et d'organisation
devrait être réglées avant d'instaurer
tel juridiction de même d'importants
travaux préparatoires devaient être
devrait être conduit par avec les
professionnels de la justice donc
demande de retrait ou avis défavorable
merci avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur
le président bonjour
le président de la République à Dijon a
fait autre chose que de rencontrer
Monsieur
notamment il est allé s'assurer de la
façon dont aujourd'hui les gens d'armes
sont formés pour recueillir la parole
des femmes qui sont victimes de violence
intrafamiliales j'étais à ses côtés je
peux vous dire que c'était tout à fait
passionnant ce qui nous a été montré
deuxièmement pardon mais il y a un
travail parlementaire qui est en cours
et ce travail a été confié à madame la
sénatrice Dominique Verrien et Madame la
Députée Émilie Chandler et si le
président de la République disait un
certain nombre de choses là des cours de
cette visite Dijon ou si moi-même je
m'exprimais vous seriez sans aucun doute
madame la première à vous exprimer pour
vous dire que nous ne respectons pas le
travail parlementaire alors souffrait
qu'il se termine je pense qu'il est en
de très bonnes mains et que ces
questions qui sont des questions
importantes trouveront laissé moi
terminer les réponses que voilà je sais
que vous consultez beaucoup je sais que
vous travaillez beaucoup et que ce sujet
est un sujet je le redis qui est traité
soyez tout à fait rassuré donc les
réponses nous les apporterons en temps
voulu madame la sénatrice
madame de La Gontrie puis madame Verrien
merci président pour pour explication de
vote faut pas qu'il y ait de malentendu
et j'entendais notre collègue rapporteur
de la commission des finances il ne
s'agit pas de créer la juridiction
spécialisée nous parlons budget
aujourd'hui donc si nous refusons
l'inscription budgétaire que nous
proposons
cela veut donc dire qu'en 2023 il n'y
aura pas de juridiction spécialisée nous
proposons simplement que la conclusion
des travaux que mène Dominique Verrien
et notre collègue député puisse trouver
sa concrétisation au cours de l'année
prochaine donc si vous refusez ces
crédits ça veut donc dire que vous
refusez quel que soit les conclusions de
cette commission et de cette mission
pardon que
c'est ces propositions
soient traduite dans la réalité c'est
donc très grave parce qu'il y a une
obstination sur ce sujet qui est
totalement incompréhensible
merci Madame Verrien
et vous savez je partage cette opinion
que il est clair que on peut pas avoir
et je l'ai dit tout à l'heure un juge
aux affaires familiales qui prend une
décision qui sont forcément être
concertées avec le juge des enfants et
en ignorant totalement ce qui se passe
sur le côté pénal parce que c'est
absolument délétère donc il faut de
toute façon trouver une solution pour
que tout le monde travaille ensemble
c'est ce qu'on appelle juridiction
spécialisée sans aujourd'hui je dois
l'avouer puisque aujourd'hui on est
plutôt en train de faire et c'est notre
mission jusqu'en jusqu'à janvier tout le
tour des bonnes pratiques dans les
différentes juridictions puisque
l'objectif de notre rapport qui sera
remis en mars l'objectif que nous nous
sommes fixés midi Chandler et moi-même
c'est de faire trois étapes au moins
deux étapes une étape à court terme
immédiate qu'est-ce qu'on peut tout de
suite mettre en œuvre pour que ça
fonctionne mieux en sachant que il y a
et nous avons par exemple entendu le
tribunal de Chalon en Champagne qui a
déjà mis pas mal de choses en place qui
fonctionnent franchement bien et à la
limite à budget constant parce que là il
s'agit de bonnes pratiques par contre ça
du coup c'est du court terme qui peut se
faire ça c'est du 2023 par contre
évidemment il y aura probablement des
choses à mettre en place mais qui sont à
plus long terme et qui demanderont comme
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure formation
parce que on voit que ceux qui pêchent
et que ce soit chez des gendarmes ou
chez les magistrats toutes sortes de
magistrats ou dans les services sociaux
aussi c'est une méconnaissance en fait
de de ce que sont les violences
conjugales donc très clairement la vraie
juridiction spécialisée telle qu'on en
rêve elle se mettra pas directement en
place en 2023 en 2023 on mettra en place
ce qui permet de fonctionner au plus
vite pour obtenir tout de suite de
meilleurs résultats mais après français
qui est un temps de formation donc
objectivement la vraie juridiction
spécialisée en 2024 la parole est à la
présence
non mais je remercie Dominique verrière
dont je connais le travail et
l'engagement et je sais que votre
mission effectivement un besoin de
travailler par étape mais vous venez de
mettre le doigt sur ce qui est quand
même le débat c'est est-ce que ce vers
quoi on va c'est un moyen constant dans
l'organisation telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui une meilleure coordination
des magistrats comme ça existe déjà d'un
certain nombre de tribunaux en sachant
que effectivement tout ça est supposé
être lié à des questions de formation
vous savez quand même quelques années
que les magistrats qui sortent de l'anmm
sont supposés de former sur les
violences d'une part d'autre part ceci
est très bien à une un détail près
c'était magistrats mutent et les
protocoles qui se mettent en place ce
qui se met en place à l'intérieur des
tribunaux et souvent contingent de
l'engagement personnel des magistrats
qui sont engagés dans ce dossier c'est
pour ça que je fais la distinction entre
coordination du travail est mise en
place une réelle interdiction
spécialisée parce que les violences
faites aux femmes sont et les
féminicides et les 80 000 violences
chaque année plus celles faites aux
enfants sont un sujet majeur de sécurité
et de politique pénale aujourd'hui que
si nous avons mis en place des parquets
spécialisés en matière de terrorisme en
matière de pédocriminalité c'est bien
parce que certaines infractions certains
types de délinquance nécessitent une
action particulière de nos magistrats
donc j'entends ce que vous nous dites
j'entends la première étape que vous
proposez ma grande crainte c'est qu'on
s'entraîne à la première étape quelle
que soit votre quel que soit votre bonne
volonté et votre engagement personnel
donc ce que nous demandons extengagement
c'est un engagement avec cet amendement
pardon c'est un engagement du ministre à
nous dire notre objectif et bien celui
d'une juridiction spécialisée et le
travail des parlementaires consiste à
préparer l'état des lieux et les pistes
possibles pour la meilleure mise en
œuvre
merci la parole est au ministre je
précise que j'ai une demande scrutin
public merci de vous y préparer je vous
allez très vite mais je vous entends
murmurer dans mon eau ça n'est plus un
murmure d'ailleurs il n'en veut pas
pardonnez-moi moi je suis respectueux du
travail qui est en cours et merci madame
de madame la sénatrice de nous avoir
redit ce que ce que vous avez dit voilà
si je disais à cet instant mais écoutez
votre travail au fond il sert à rien on
l'attend on l'attend pas mais on parle
des crédits vous mettez la charrue avant
les beux pardonnez-moi de vous le dire
donc voilà ce que je vous ai dit vous
cherchez de la politique vous cherchez à
présenter le sujet et au fond je
voudrais quand même vous rappeler mais
vous le savez regardez ce que nous avons
fait regardez ce que vous avez fait
regardez en terme budgétaire ce que nous
avons consacré et c'est bien légitime au
vif ce que l'on appelle les vives c'est
presque devenu un nom commun aujourd'hui
hélas et malheureusement franchement on
n'a pas de leçon à recevoir moi
j'attends que le travail parlementaire
soit terminé voilà c'est comme ça que ça
doit aller et si je faisais le contraire
comme vous cherchez parfois le buzz pas
toujours et la polémique vous diriez
mais vous ne respectez pas vous ne
respectez pas le travail des
parlementaires alors voilà pas
polémiquer ici ce soir le Sénat est un
lieu d'apaisement très bien
j'ai été saisi donc je le redis d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
socialiste sur l'amendement 308 je vous
rappelle que la vie de la commission est
défavorable à vie du Gouvernement est
défavorable il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
344 exprimé 344 pour l'amendement 92
contre 252 l'amendement n'est pas adopté
et je passe au 285 madame kukermann
défendu à la Commission
alors je demande le retrait de cet
amendement qui crée un programme doté de
30 millions d'euros et qui est dédié à
la création d'une politique de
régulation carcérale au risque de vous
surprendre chers collègues je partage le
propos sur le fond je rappelle
régulièrement dans le cas de mes travaux
qu'une politique pénitentiaire ne peut
pas se résumer une politique immobilière
avec la construction de places
supplémentaires en détention toutefois
et c'est là sans doute où nous
divergeons il me semble illusoire de
croire que nous allons tout pouvoir
régler à court terme avec un mécanisme
de régulation carcérale d'ailleurs si le
comité des états généraux de la justice
aborde cette piste c'est davantage dans
une perspective de moyen terme avec un
double mécanisme de seuil d'alerte et le
seuil critique votre amendement nous
permet cependant interroger le
gouvernement sur le site qu'il entend
donner à cette préconisation donc une
demande de retrait à défaut ce sera
défavorable merci monsieur le ministre
position identique monsieur le Président
merci je suis saisi d'une demande de
scrutin
juste pour dire que personne ne me
surprend et compris ma philosophie fait
que la contradiction humaine et son
propre dépassement et ce qui nous fait
agir donc je vais le maintenir cependant
et je pense qu'en tout cas effectivement
ça fait partie des sujets qui sont
toujours devant nous toujours à débattre
toujours à remettre en questionnement
parce que très certainement et vous
l'avez dit l'un ne va pas sans l'autre
et nous avions là plutôt des amendements
d'appel et j'en profite également à
monsieur le Président pour dire que par
parallélisme des formes en tout cas nous
avons plutôt le même type d'amendement
qui va suivre tout à l'heure en matière
de protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
mais qui est dans la même veine en tout
cas qui doit nous amener toujours à
garder raison en matière de construction
un pénitentiaire
merci je suis saisi donc d'une demande
scrutin public par le groupe les
républicain sur l'amendement 285 la
ville de la commission est défavorable à
vie du gouvernement et défavorable le
scrutin est ouvert
ça nous demande à voter le scrutin est
clos
votant 344 exprimé 344 pour 92 contre
252 l'amendement n'est pas adopté et je
passe au 238 monsieur dessus
oui c'est un abonnement qui vise à créer
un fond pour la
création d'un programme d'accompagnement
justice santé mentale en réalité ça
s'inspire d'une d'un dispositif qui
existe au Québec depuis 20 ans qui est
un programme qui permet d'accompagner
d'encadrer les personnes présentant une
problématique de santé mentale ou ayant
commis des infractions criminelles dans
le processus judiciaire tout en leur
donnant les moyens pour améliorer leur
situation
en France on sait que les problématiques
santé mentales touchent 8 fois plus de
personnes que dans la société
carcérale que dans la société libre se
présente amendement ainsi pour objet de
lancer une expérimentation pour déployer
le programme d'accompagnement justice
santé mentale en France
merci avis de la commission sur la
porteur
alors je propose un avis défavorable sur
cet amendement alors j'entends bien bien
sûr les enjeux qui sont soulevés par
notre collègue mais ne sont pas que la
création d'un fond spécifique soit le
véhicule budgétaire le plus adapté au
contraire il me semble que ce doit être
une préoccupation partagée par
l'ensemble des acteurs de la justice de
manière transversale des actions sont
déjà menées en ce sens par le ministère
que ce soit auprès des mineurs ou dans
les établissements pénitentiaires et
monsieur le garde des sceaux pourra sans
doute nous en dire plus avis défavorable
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
sénateur d'abord je vous rappeler que
les soins psychiatriques aux personnes
détenues relèvent du ministère de la
santé et de la prévention premier chef
mais cependant cet enjeu mobilise au
quotidien tous les services de l'État et
notamment l'administration pénitentiaire
alors
c'est dans ce cadre que le ministère de
la Justice et le ministère de la Santé
mène un travail conjoint pour déployer
les solutions visant à améliorer les
modalités de prise en charge des
personnes détenues nécessitant des soins
psychiatriques et cette action conjointe
s'inscrit dans une feuille de route
2019-2022 signée par les deux ministères
et qui sera reconduite à compter de 2023
dans ces conditions je propose un
retrait de cet amendement et à défaut
j'ai mis un avis défavorable
merci il est maintenu il est maintenu je
mets au voile 238
avec deux avis défavorables qui pour
qui contre
acheter
monsieur dessus le 237 oui c'est un
amendement qui a pour objet de déployer
des crédits pour le recrutement
d'éducateur de la PJJ la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse est un secteur
emploi une crise matérielle et de
vocation depuis des années pourtant les
crédits affectés au programme de PJJ ce
concentre majoritairement dans la
poursuite de création de nouveaux
centres éducatifs fermés très coûteux
sans remédier à la crise que subit le
personnel de la PJJ la controle générale
des lieux privatifs de liberté a mis en
garde sur la nécessité d'établir un
bilan actualisé des structures de centre
éducatif fermé existant et d'arrêter la
construction de nouvelles le président
allemand a ainsi pour objet de
redéployer les crédits afin de renforcer
les moyens financiers et humains des
acteurs de la PJ qui assurent des
missions d'éducation et de prévention
auprès des mineurs
merci avis de la commission
avis défavorable sur cet amendement
alors je partage bien évidemment les
préoccupations de notre collègue sur la
PJJ et notamment sur la nécessité d'en
re-valoriser les métiers qui souffrent
d'un décisif d'attractivité alors même
qu'ils sont essentiels et répondent à
une mission de service public je ne suis
toutefois pas d'accord sur le manque de
moyens que vous mettez en avant ni même
sur la priorité qui serait donnée à la
construction de centre éducatif fermé
ainsi la hausse de 10,3% des crédits à
louer à la PJ est en grande en très
grande partie tirée par la hausse des
dépenses de personnel c'est notamment
liée à la hausse du point d'indice et
surtout à l'effet en année pleine des
revalorisations qui ont été décidées
dans le cadre du Ségur certains corps
commun spécifiques tels que les
éducateurs les travailleurs sociaux les
psychologues ont en outre bénéficié de
mesure catégorielles des évolutions
positives sont donc déjà prévues dans le
cadre du projet de loi de finance pour
2003 23 donc ce sera la vie défavorable
merci avis du gouvernement
oui merci monsieur le Président mais ma
vie évidemment s'agissant des crédits
personnels PJJ pour 2023 c'est 645
millions c'est une augmentation de 77
millions par rapport à la loi de finance
2022 une croissance de plus de 14 % et
s'agissant des créations d'emplois de la
PJJ il est prévu 92 emplois
supplémentaires soit une hausse par
rapport au recrutement 2022 à hauteur de
51 dans ces conditions évidemment le
Gouvernement est défavorable
merci je mets aux voiles 237 avec deux
avis négatifs qui est pour
quiconque
on va faire très court c'est amendement
vise à revaloriser la rémunération des
greffiers
avis de la commission de se rapporter
qui propose l'augmentation des crédits à
louer au greffiers tout d'abord dire à
l'ensemble des collègues que je partage
aussi cette préoccupation sur la
situation des greffiers qu'on a que j'ai
personnellement rencontré leurs
organisations il est clair que nous
avons accumulé un certain retard dans le
traitement de leur charge de travail
dans la revalorisation de leur
rémunération il faut toutefois pas nier
les efforts entreprises ces deux
dernières années ainsi que ceux à venir
1811 postes de greffiers seraient l'an
prochain et 1500 d'ici 2027 la montée en
charge est progressive puisqu'il faut
bien sûr tenir compte du temps de
formation initiale de même la
rémunération des greffiers augmenterait
d'environ 150 euros par mois cette année
ajoutez des crédits dans le montant est
par ailleurs davantage un montant
d'appel ne me semble donc pas nécessaire
demande de retrait sinon défavorable
avis du gouvernement
les greffiers jouent un rôle absolument
Tessentiel et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le ministère a souhaité mettre
en place une revalorisation les termes
viennent de vous en être rappelé
concrètement ça représente près de 12%
de la hausse de la rémunération des
greffiers depuis 2020 soit déjà près de
1500 euros par an et je vous annonce que
cette hausse va se poursuivre et qu'elle
est déjà prise en compte dans le projet
de budget dans les 15 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui seront répartis
entre les différents corps de greffe
dans ces conditions c'est une demande de
retrait ou un avis défavorable
merci je mets au voile 236 avec deux
avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre
rejeté le 325 monsieur
merci monsieur le Président de
pénitentiaire de Bordeaux Gradignan est
l'un des plus vétustes de France en
juillet dernier la contrôleur général
les lieux de prévention de liberté a
fait un constat accablant le taux
d'occupation globale est de 199% et ce
taux monte à 235% pour la maison d'arrêt
des hommes 145 cellules sont triplées
avec un matelas au sol et de nombreux
détenus ont un espace personnel de moins
de 3 mètres carrés dans la foulée le 13
octobre le juge des référés du tribunal
administratif de Bordeaux à enjoint le
ministère de la Justice à mettre en
oeuvre neuf mesures dont la rénovation
des cellules l'amendement que je vous
propose d'adopter vise à allouer les
fonds nécessaires à cette rénovation des
mesures d'urgence doivent être prises
afin de garantir le respect des droits
fondamentaux d'autant que le chantier de
reconstruction de la prison ne se
terminera qu'en 2027 et restera
largement insuffisant ces travaux
permettront à peine d'absorber la
surpopulation actuelle malheureusement
la prison de Gradignan n'est pas un cas
isolé
en 2020 la justice française a alerté
sur les conditions de vie indigne des
détenus dans 35 établissements
pénitentiaires la France a également été
condamnée à 18 reprises par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme car les
conditions de détention violent
l'article 3 de la Convention européenne
des droits de l'homme en janvier 2020
cette même cour européenne a condamné la
France à prendre des mesures
structurelles pour mettre un terme à la
surpopulation carcérale merci avis de la
commission sur le rapporteur
alors je demande le retrait de cet
amendement qui me semble davantage
d'être un amendement d'appel pour
attirer l'attention effectivement sur la
situation du centre pénitentiaire de
Bordeaux Gradignan alors à titre
personnel je prends d'ailleurs
les choses en considération c'est votre
votre appel puisque j'ai prévu en
qualité de rapporteur spécial de me
rendre en 2023 dans au centre
pénitentiaire de Bordeaux Gradignan pour
constater les choses sur place mais je
veux signaler mes collègues que dans le
cadre des travaux budgétaires que j'ai
menés j'ai interrogé le directeur
d'administration pénitentiaire sur la
rénovation des établissements la
construction nouvelle place dans le
cadre du Plan 15000 ne doit pas en effet
conduire à négliger surtout l'entretien
et la rénovation de l'existant je vous
communique donc les chiffres obtenus
dans ce cadre cette année
l'administration pénitentiaire dispose
d'un budget inédit de 142 millions
d'euros dédiés à la maintenance et
l'entretien des bâtiments ce montant est
plus élevé que la moyenne des 110 110
millions d'euros sur la période
2018-2022 et que la moyenne à 40 à 60
millions d'euros de 2014 à 2016 qui nous
avait conduit accumulé un apport en
retard dans la d'établissement parfois
indignes le ministère pourra sans doute
vous en dire plus sur la répartition de
ces fonds demande de retraits ou sinon
avis défavorable merci evil du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
ces situations de tension pénitentiaire
sont une véritable préoccupation pour le
gouvernement il y a deux façons de
d'envisager sur le plan immobilier des
choses soit la construction d'un nouvel
établissement soit rénovation s'agissant
de Bordeaux Gradignan j'ai déjà évoqué
la situation avec madame la Présidente
Delattre et je voudrais vous dire que
pour répondre à ces enjeux qui sont des
enjeux évidemment majeurs le ministère
agit la mise en service progressive du
nouveau centre pénitentiaire en cours de
construction dans la première phase sera
livrée en 2023 et la seconde en 2026 ce
qui permettra la création de 250 places
net supplémentaires des travaux déjà
engagés qui permettront notamment de
répondre aux injonctions du tribunal
administratif s'agissant en particulier
de la luminosité des cellules avec le
changement des châssis les plus dégradés
amélioration de l'éclairage d'autres
travaux à hauteur de 665
55000 euros pardonnez-moi sont également
prévus tels que la remise en état des
douches actuellement en cours la
résorption des infiltrations reprises
des peintures des cellules et je vous
confirme que les crédits nécessaires aux
travaux d'amélioration de la prison de
Gradignan sont inscrits dans l'enveloppe
de rénovation des établissements qui je
le rappelle a doublé depuis 2018 pour
atteindre plus de 140 millions d'euros
en 2023 c'est pourquoi je vous propose
un retrait des faux j'aimais bien sûr un
avis défavorable
merci je mets aux voix le 325 avec deux
avis défavorables qui pour
quiconque
il est rejeté le 312 oui monsieur Artano
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement de la présidente de latte
frais en fait Eco au rapport sénatorial
mais organisé la nation en temps de
crise qui avait pointu du doigt que les
services pénitentiaires d'insertion et
probation avaient connu de graves
perturbations notamment dans les
connexions à distance à défaut
d'équipement il y a des défaut
d'équipements adaptés qui rend donc
rendu ce travail est difficile ainsi la
numérisation de la justice doit
évidemment ne pas négliger les spips qui
lui qui peuvent assumer une grande
partie de leur mission à distance pour
le peu qui puisse s'y connecter
avis de la commission
alors c'est une demande de retraite
cette amendement qui vise à majorer donc
un million d'euros les crédits à
destination et services pénitentiaire
d'insertion et de probation notre
collègue a juste titre insisté sur
l'équipement informatique et la
numérisation des spips je vais à cet
égard rappelait que le 30 transformation
numérique de la justice concerne
l'ensemble des services et des métiers
et donc les spips et les crédits ne sont
pas forcément labellisés sur ceux de
l'administration pénitentiaire car les
projets sont parfois pilotés par le
Secrétariat général du ministère de la
Justice ainsi concernant les équipements
pour le télétravail le ministère a
confirmé que désormais l'ensemble des
agents ayant des fonctions pouvaient
être exercées à distance dispose
d'équipement nécessaire demande de
retrait sinon avis défavorable merci
avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre mais ma vie
retirer merci le 341 qui le défende sur
le testeur merci monsieur le Président
notre collègue madame Martin filleul
propose par cet amendement de favoriser
l'accès à Internet en prison
elle fait remarquer qu'en 2020 la
Contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté avaient estimé dans
un rapport que cet accès devait être
considéré comme prioritaire considérant
que cette prix vacation était une
entrave à de nombreux droits
fondamentaux dont la liberté
d'expression le droit de l'éducation
ainsi que le droit d'une personne
détenue à la préparation de son retour
au sein de la société la même année la
mission d'information du Sénat pour la
lutte contre l'électronisme et pour
l'inclusion numérique qualifiée cette
situation de double peine pour les
personnes privées de liberté plusieurs
pays ont d'ailleurs introduit des accès
contrôlés et j'insiste sur le fait que
c'est contrôlé ou cadré à Internet en
cellule notamment l'Allemagne la Suisse
et les États-Unis donc tel est le sens
de cette amendement merci
avis de la commission
s'agit encore d'une demande de retrait
puisque il est évoqué par question
interdiction totale en detation
j'aimerais nuancer vos propos c'est en
effet un sujet que j'ai abordé également
dans les travaux dans mes travaux
budgétaires depuis l'année dernière une
expérimentation est menée pour équiper
les cellules de maison d'arrêt de
tablettes sécurisée ces tablettes
permettent aux détenus d'accéder à leurs
dossier ou de suivre le traitement de
leur demande y compris de formation
cette expérimentation me semble très
intéressante elle va se poursuivre en
2023 donc c'est une demande de retrait à
défaut défavorable merci avis du
gouvernement c'est le même position sur
le président merci il est maintenu et il
est maintenu alors explication de votre
monsieur le Président je fais juste
observer en une ligne ce qui va vous
plaire que certes c'est en cours
l'expérimentation est en cours madame
Fillol veut tout simplement la favoriser
l'accélérer
merci je mets aux voix le 341 avec deux
avis défavorables que pour
qui contre
de 286 madame kukerman est défendu avis
de la commission
alors une demande de retrait pour cette
amendement il semble que votre appel est
satisfait par le droit existant et par
les réformes qui ont été engagées par le
ministère certes sans doute un rythme
trop peu soutenu encore mais par exemple
dans le cadre de la loi de programmation
nous avions voté une diversification du
panel des peines applicables aux mineurs
pour mieux adapter les peines au mineur
le ministère propose également
professionnel des formations
aménagements de peine pour intégrer ces
évolutions dans leur pratique donc une
demande de retrait à défaut défavorable
merci avez du gouvernement la même
position ce président merci je suis
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
sur l'amendement 286
il va être procédé etc etc allez
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin éclos
votant décidément 344 expirés 344 pour
92 contre 252 l'amendement n'est pas
adopté
nous allons procéder au vote des crédits
la mission de justice je n'ai été saisi
d'aucune demande d'explication de vote
dans l'expiration etc des délais je mets
aux voix les crédits de la mission qui
est pour
quiconque
ils sont adoptés rassurez-vous monsieur
le Président buffet il y a encore des
amendements j'appelle en discussion les
articles 44 44 bis et 44 TER qui sera
attachées je mets aux voix d'abord
l'article 44 monsieur le Président
buffet non alors 44 qui est pour
qui est contre
adopté
le 44 bis qui est pour
qui contre adopter
à l'article 44 TER un amendement 269
Monsieur lequester Merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre cet
article a pour objet de supprimer la
référence dans la loi à l'anciennement
individuel ou plutôt de proroger la
suppression de l'inscription dans la loi
de l'enseignement individuel or vous
savez mes chers collègues que cela
figure dans notre législation depuis
1875 et je me souviens des débats très
forts qu'il y a eu dans cet assemblée en
2009 le rapporteur du texte est alors
Jean-René le cerf et il avait plaidé
avec beaucoup de force pour que l'on
maintienne cette perspective
de lancer l'huilement individuelle qui
bien entendu renforce la dignité les
conditions de détention et favorisent
la réintégration la préparation à la
réintégration sociale des détenus et
donc il nous paraît que revenir
là-dessus est un mauvais signe même si
nous savons que c'est une perspective
qui ne pourrait être atteinte jusqu'au
prix de nombreux d'efforts nous ne
voulons pas que l'on revienne sur ce
principe
avis de la commission sur le rapporteur
la vie est défavorable sur cet
amendement de suppression nous pouvons
pas bien sûr nous satisfaire de devoir
prolonger une nouvelle fois le moratoire
sur le principe de lancer individuel en
maison d'arrêt pour autant il faut bien
reconnaître que cette objective est
totalement inatteable d'ici la fin de
l'année y compris par les mécanismes de
régulation que vous évoquez je ne vous
donnerai qu'un exemple alors que nombre
de détenus avaient considérablement
baissé durant la crise sanitaire le taux
d'enseignement individuel était toujours
que de 35,2 % au 1er juillet 2020 si je
suis donc d'accord pour dire que notre
politique pénitentiaire ne doit pas se
résumer un programme immobilier je suis
défavorable à la suppression de
l'article qui nous changera pas la
situation merci
le ministre
oui merci monsieur le Président mais
j'aimerais moi tellement qu'on règle
mais comme vous cette question
l'enseignement individuel bon
les socialistes avaient voté d'ailleurs
la prolongation de du moratoire mais
nous on vous demande de le faire
pourquoi parce qu'on est au pied du mur
vraiment au sens propre comme au sens
figuré d'ailleurs vous savez moi
j'aimerais bien qu'il y ait une
génération de prison spontanée de place
nette spontanée mais il faut les faire
donc tant qu'on les a pas construites on
ne peut pas régler cette question et il
y a un principe de réalité qui s'impose
à nous voilà moralement vous avez raison
je comprends parfaitement tout ça enfin
je sais pas comment on peut régler la
question et moi évidemment je suis
défavorable à votre amendement attendons
que les prisons soient construites on
s'est engagé 2027 et ensuite je pense
que cette question sera réglée
merci je mets au voile 269 avec deux
avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre
15 monsieur le rapporteur
oui alors justement on évoque dans cet
article 44 terres la position de
prolonger sur 31 décembre 2027 la
possibilité de déroger au principe dans
ses mouvements individuel des personnes
détenues en maison d'arrêt en
application de l'article L 2134 du code
pénitentiaire si cette prorogation est
nécessaire et n'en demeure pas moins un
aveu des retards concédés par le
gouvernement en matière de politique
pénitentielles ces dernières ne pouvant
se résumer à la seule construction de
place de détention supplémentaire par
coordination avec le prolongement du
moratoire de votre rapporteur propose
par cet amendement que le gouvernement
remède de nouveau rapport en 2025 et en
2027 ce qui permettra au Parlement de
prendre connaissance intervalles
réguliers de l'exécution de programme
immobilier pénitentiaire et de leur
impact quand au respect l'objectif de
placement en cellule individuelle
il convient de déroger à la règle parce
que d'habitude le gouvernement se lève
toujours et dit nous on est défavorable
au rapport parce que c'est du boulot en
plus évidemment voilà puis on n'a pas
toujours les oui mais alors là à vrai
dire je vous demande de me faire
confiance sur ma bonne mine et je
comprends bien ça rapporte officiel que
ça n'est pas suffisant donc on va vous
les faire les rapports oui bien sûr je
suis favorable à votre amende
très bien donc sur l'amendement 15 de la
commission avec un avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre il est adopté je mets au
voile article 44 terre qui est pour
qui contre il est adopté après l'article
n'est pas défendue après l'article 44 le
338 monsieur le Custer ou oui oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je connais
le discours
réitérer sans foiré itérée sur les
rapports il s'agit toutefois de prendre
en compte c'est le souhait de Madame
Fillol les conditions de travail des
personnels des types des spips je vous
remercie merci avis de la commission
avis défavorable par rapport
effectivement cette demande de rapport
qui sont toujours pas un moyen d'obtenir
les informations souhaitées en revanche
le gouvernement engagé un travail sur
l'évaluation de la charge de travail des
magistrales pourra peut-être nous
indiquer si l'envisage de conduire la
même démarche pour les autres métiers du
ministère de la Justice eux aussi soumis
à d'importantes tensions avis
défavorablement monsieur le ministre
ur il revient au galop et que le
gouvernement a pas envie de faire un
rapport d'autant que on a déjà la
réponse à toutes ces questions grâce au
recrutement le nombre de dossiers suivis
par les cépip a diminué de 13%, il est
passé de 80 dossiers 71
défavorable si je mets aux voix cet
amendement avec deux avis défavorables
qui pour
quiconque il est rejeté mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
21h30 pour l'examen de la mission
administration générale et territoriale
de l'État la séance
est suspendue